Hallo, hier ist Chaos Radio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 184, mein Name Tim Pritlove und nach einer, ja, kürzeren Pause geht's hier wieder weiter. Und ich hab mir diesmal ein bisschen Zeit gelassen, weil ich mir nicht so richtig war, sicher war, mit welchem Thema ich denn jetzt hier eigentlich mal wieder voranschreiten möchte. Das Programm ist mir manchmal ein bisschen nerdlastig und manchmal sind es auch so die etwas anderen Themen, die mich reizen. Und so soll es auch heute sein und ich wollte mal ein heißes Eisen anfassen, was immer so einen kleinen etepetete-Touch hat, wenn man darüber redet, nämlich die Bundeswehr beziehungsweise grundsätzlich auch so die Frage der internationalen Sicherheitspolitik und was da alles noch so dranhängt. Und dazu freue ich mich zu begrüßen als Gesprächspartner für die heutige Sendung. Thomas Wiegold, hallo.
Hallo.
Der du da ganz eifrig am Bloggen bist über dieses Thema, bzw. bist du nicht nur am Bloggen, sondern das beschäftigt dich ja überhaupt schon seit längerer Zeit, oder?
Na ja, so seit 17, 18 Jahren. Ich sage immer, ich bin Journalist und Blog ist ein journalistisches Medium für mich. Und da schreibe ich ein bisschen über die Bundeswehr, über Auslandseinsätze, über deutsche Sicherheits- und Verteidigungspolitik. Und eigentlich auch immer mit diesem journalistischen Anspruch.
Auge geradeaus heißt das?
Ja, ist doch ein programmatischer Titel.
Auf jeden Fall.
Vor allem ist es im Deutschen so schön doppeldeutig, weil es ja nicht nur den militärischen Befehl bedeutet, sondern bedeutet ja auch ein bisschen nach vorne gucken.
Also hast du visionäre Anteile. Aber damit hat es ja nicht angefangen. Also hast du eine klassische Journalisten-Ausbildung genossen?
Aber hallo, ja. Ich bin seit 30 Jahren professioneller Journalist, richtig mit Volontariat bei der Deutsch-Presse-Agentur, 18 Jahre bei Nachrichten-Agenturen, dann 11 Jahre beim Fokus und seit einem Jahr freiberuflich.
Und was hat dich dazu bewegt, dich da freiberuflich zu machen, wenn du vorher so in großen Unternehmungen unterwegs warst?
Naja, ich wollte so ein bisschen mein eigenes Dicken machen und also ein bisschen tiefer in Themen reingehen, die in den normalen Medien eigentlich auch immer am Rande sind. Also man muss ja sehen, was ich da mache, ist ein Minderheitensport oder ein Orchideenfach. In den großen Medien tauchen diese Fragen, Sicherheitsverteilungspolitik, Auslandseinsätze immer dann auf, wenn es geknallt hat zum Beispiel, also wenn es wieder Tod in Afghanistan gegeben hat oder so, dann ist Interesse da oder die Wehrpflicht wird abgeschafft. Aber das ist immer sehr punktuell. Also die kontinuierliche Beobachtung dieses Umfelds, die ist doch relativ selten.
Aber ist das nicht bei allen Themen irgendwie so?
Na ja, es gibt Themen, die sind mehr im Mainstream verankert, muss man auch einfach so sagen. Also mein Eindruck ist schon, dass den meisten Leuten hierzulande, was die Bundeswehr macht, eigentlich normalerweise relativ egal ist.
Das ist so ein etwas fernes Wesen, von dem man immer weiß, dass es das gibt, aber eigentlich läuft man nicht selber hin und beschäftigt sich damit.
Und es gab mal einen Bundespräsidenten, der das auf die schöne Formel des freundlichen Desinteresses brachte. Und ich finde, das beschreibt es eigentlich ganz gut.
Welcher war denn das?
Den haben wir nicht mehr. Das war der, der dann... Aber er hat schon, glaube ich, ganz recht.
Welcher war es denn?
Ich meine, es war Köhler. Ich hoffe, ich vertue mich jetzt nicht. Ich müsste nachgucken, aber nach meiner Erinnerung war es Köhler.
Aber Köhler, ist das ja so eine Sache, was er mal gesagt hat oder nicht?
Was er gesagt hat, ist nicht so eine Sache, sondern was daraus geworden ist. Und wie damit umgegangen wurde, auch von ihm selbst, das ist natürlich eine ganz andere Frage, ist schon klar.
Aber vielleicht nochmal kurz bei dir bleibend, was beim Fokus, aber du hast quasi immer Bundeswehr schon so als Schwerpunktthema gehabt.
Warum?
Haben sie gedient?
Nö, natürlich nicht. Mit einer kannten Krieg sind zwei Weigere.
Wie kommt man dann zu dem Thema?
Also ich sag dann immer, zu Bismarcks Zeiten war der deutsche Botschafter im Vatikan ein Protestant. Und die Kollegen, die über Gesundheitspolitik berichten, müssen ja auch nicht krank sein. Also von daher finde ich, das kann man schon machen. Nee, aber mal ernsthaft. Ich bin da reingerutscht, ganz interessant, nämlich 1993, als es den ersten bewaffneten Auslandseinsatz deutscher Soldaten seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg gab, nämlich in Somalia damals, vielleicht erinnert sich ja noch der eine oder andere. Das Ganze endete dann relativ abrupt, Stichwort Black Hawk Down, das ist vielleicht noch ein bisschen bekannter.
Wo die Amerikaner da irgendwie durch die Straßen gefläuft wurden. Auch die Amis, nur kann man nichts ausstiegen.
Ja, weil auch die amerikanische öffentliche Stimmung sofort kippte und das ging dann nicht mehr weiter. Jedenfalls habe ich damals gesagt, es ist der erste bewaffnete deutsche Auslandseinsatz, das ist etwas Neues und da muss man auch aus deutscher Perspektive drüber berichten. Ich war damals bei der Nachrichtenagentur AP, Associated Press, die hatte damals noch einen deutschen Dienst, inzwischen gibt es den nicht mehr so. Und die ganze Berichterstattung aus Mogadishu damals wurde von Amerikanern gemacht. Und für die Amerikaner waren natürlich die Deutschen jetzt Nation Nummer 17 in einem multinationalen Einsatz. Also ob die Deutschen kamen oder die Marokkaner oder wer auch immer interessierte, die ja natürlich wirklich so am Rande. Also habe ich gesagt, da muss ein deutscher Journalistin aus deutscher Perspektive für Deutschland darüber berichten. Das habe ich gemacht.
Aber zu dem Zeitpunkt hast du quasi Bundeswehr noch gar nicht auf dem Zerplung?
Nicht wirklich. Nein, immer mal wie man das so hat. Also es gibt ja die typischen Sachen, die man im Volontariat hat. Das hat jeder Journalist. Irgendwo gibt es dann mal Berührungspunkte, weiß ich nicht, mit der örtlichen Garnison. In meinem Fall natürlich, weil ich in Kiel mein Volontariat gemacht habe. Und da ergab es sich natürlich, dass man über die Gorch Fock mal was geschrieben hat oder ähnliche Dinge. Aber das waren wirklich nur so punktuelle Ausnahmesachen.
Und nun warst du da, wie lange?
Am ersten Mal drei Wochen und dann noch zweimal zwei Wochen.
Und?
Rückblickend sage ich, ich war ziemlich blauäugig. Was ich dann gemerkt habe, als ein paar Wochen, nachdem ich aus Mogadischu zurückgekehrt war, ein Kollege von mir, der Berliner Fotograf Hansi Kraus, da totgeschlagen wurde vom Mob. Das war dann auch so ein, ich war eigentlich dabei, aber es war so ein Aha-Erlebnis, nach dem Motto verdammt, das hätte mir auch ganz genauso passieren können. Ich bin genau da rumgelaufen, wo er auch rumgelaufen ist. Und da dachte ich, hast du einfach ein Scheißglück gehabt. Also, gut, jedenfalls hab ich da, also ich war dann halt in Mogadishu ab und zu und auch vor allem dann in Belletveen, wo die Deutschen stationiert waren. Und es war ja in dem Sinne, nicht so, wie es jetzt zum Beispiel in Afghanistan ist, es war ja vom eigentlichen Einsatz her, den die Bundeswehr gemacht hat, relativ belanglos. Da hat sich natürlich seitdem eine ganze Menge verändert. Aber es war, glaube ich, im Bewusstsein deutscher Streitkräfte, auch im Bewusstsein der Politik, war das einfach eine Zensur.
Was heißt das, es war belanglos? War das jetzt nur so ein, ja, wir waren jetzt auch da und haben so getan, als wären wir beteiligt gewesen?
Nee, nee, nee, also die Idee dahinter war, ja die Deutschen hatten ja ganz bewusst keinen Kampfauftrag damals, sondern sie hatten den Auftrag, Logistik, also Nachschubversorgung zu machen für eine indische Brigade. Dummerweise kamen die nie. Und dann haben die sich halt anders beschäftigt, weil man ist ja Bundeswehrmann, ist ja deutscher Soldat, dann haben die Sachen, die auch sicherlich sinnvoll waren, also es klingt jetzt ein bisschen verniedlichend, aber es war schon eine Leistung, also Brunnen bohren, unterstützen das Krankenhaus, das Örtliche wieder auf Vordermann zu bringen. Also die haben durchaus Sachen gemacht, die damals sinnvoll waren oder zumindest sinnvoll erschienen, die aber eigentlich keine Soldatenaufgabe waren.
Da scheint ja so ein bisschen das Image auch der Bundeswehr zu sein, so wir kommen und wir bohren die Brunnen und wir bauen die Krankenhäuser wieder auf und wir tun immer Gutes so, auch so ein bisschen aus der Angst heraus, der Geschichte, dass man nicht unbedingt jetzt so als Todesengel vor Ort aufschlagen möchte. Kann das sein?
Na ja, das ist dann weniger der Bundeswehr geschuldet als der deutschen Politik, die gerade bei Afghanistan über Jahre hinweg versucht hat, diesen Eindruck zu vermitteln. Also den Eindruck, eigentlich schicken wir das technische Hilfswerk hin und dass die Waffen dabei haben, na ja gut, das ist zum eigenen Schutz, wenn mal die Bösen kommen. Dass natürlich der Auftrag von Streitkräften ganz andere ist, ganz davon abgesehen, dass Streitkräfte irgendwo hinzuschicken immer die teuerste Lösung ist, weil durch den ganzen Aufwand, das Drumherum, die Logistik, die eigene Absicherung, ist es natürlich teurer, als wenn man das THW einfach hinschickt. Aber es hat auch andere Gründe, die dahinterstecken.
Welche?
Im Puncto Afghanistan wird es ja auch inzwischen klar eingestanden, das ist auch ein Kampfauftrag.
Das heißt, dieser Wandel, der sich damals mit dem Einsatz in Somalia das erste Mal abgezeichnet hat, ist eigentlich schon längst vollzogen?
Der ist schon längst vollzogen, ja. Also vielleicht noch nicht so ganz in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung, aber im Bewusstsein der Streitkräfte schon lange.
Bleiben wir doch vielleicht erstmal so bei dem Allgemeinen der Bundeswehr. Ich glaube, es ist auch nicht unbedingt jedem so klar, wie eigentlich so ein Apparat funktioniert. Du dürftest da ja auch ein bisschen Einblick genommen haben, weil du wahrscheinlich auch viel Kontakt hast mit den entsprechenden Entscheidungsleuten. Meine lange Zeit war so nach dem Krieg. Klar gab es erstmal keine Streitkräfte und nie wieder Krieg, von deutschem Boden ausgehen, etc., irgendwann sah man dann die allgemeine Bedrohungslage durch den Kalten Krieg wiederum als so schlimm an, dass man dann doch wieder eine eingeführt hat. Aber immer so mit diesem Beigeschmack, na ja, das ist aber jetzt das Gegenteil der Wehrmacht. Das ist jetzt meine Interpretation. Das ist ja nicht ganz falsch. Ja, wir sind jetzt mal bewusst irgendwie überhaupt nicht Nazi und wir haben irgendwie ganz andere Ziele und wir werden das auch immer und ewig so beibehalten. Und daraus kommt ja auch so dieses, wir machen keine Kampfeinsätze, sondern wir sind ja hier nur zur Verteidigung da und so weiter. Und das ging ja auch lange Zeit eben so bis eben bis Ende der 80er Jahre, nachdem sich dann...
Sozusagen die Bedrohung durch den Warschauer Pakt sich mehr oder weniger in Luft auflöste.
Genau, weil sich der Warschauer Pakt in Luft auflöste.
Ziemlich genauso.
Ja, und mir nichts dir nichts, auch alte Gegner dem eigenen Regierungsbündnis, dem NATO-Bündnis beitraten. Aber ich weiß nicht, inwieweit du die Zeit vorher auch bewerben kannst. Man wird sicherlich auch noch mal ein bisschen zurückgeschaut haben. Du bist ja auch quasi Bürger Westdeutschlands gewesen. Jahrzehntelang. Jahrzehntelang gewesen sozusagen mit Erfahrung. Inwiefern hat denn die Bundeswehr dieses ursprüngliche Versprechen auch eingelöst?
Na ja, es war ja ein Versprechen, das nie abgefordert wurde. Also jetzt in den Zeiten der Blockkonfrontation. Da saßen ja alle, halt die Deutschen genauso wie Unmengen von Amerikanern, Belgiern, Franzosen, Niederländern, Kanadiern, was sich heute ja keiner mehr bewusst war, saßen alle irgendwo in Westdeutschland rum und warteten auf den Angriff des Warschauer Paktes. Also das war ja eine Situation, die, ich sag nur, drei Kreuze und verdammtes Glück gehabt, nie eingetreten ist. Von daher ist es natürlich müßig, was hätte das bedeutet. Also es hätte vermutlich zur Hochzeit des Kalten Krieges, der dann ein heißer geworden wäre, die Vernichtung Deutschlands auf beiden Seiten bedeutet. Ja und letztendlich wären wahrscheinlich irgendwann auch Atomwaffen eingesetzt worden.
Das droht auf jeden Fall.
Ja, natürlich.
Das war ja auch so eigentlich, dass, also zumindest die junge Gesellschaft, das ist das, woran ich mich jetzt selbst erinnern kann, weil da war ich quasi Teil davon in den 80er Jahren. Das war so dieses Damoklesschwert, was über allen schwebte und was, was weiß ich, in allem möglichen Auswirkungen hatte, nicht wahr? Die Friedensbewegungen, die Grünen sind da ein Teil davon und auch so banale Sachen, so was weiß ich, so neue deutsche Welle, Spaßgesellschaft, ja, man streift diese ganze Bedrohung ab, indem man sich auch zu dem totalen Warnwitz hingibt. Und dann hat sich einfach viel geändert, aber auf der anderen Seite, gut, ich meine, es ist vielleicht nicht abgerufen worden in dem Sinne, dass es nie zu diesem Ernstfall kam. Aber das ist ja gar nicht das, was ich meine. Sondern es war so dieses, wir sind jetzt eine andere Bundeswehr, wir stehen da staatstreu, wir sind da nicht Nazis, wir haben einen rechtsstaatlichen Auftrag, den wir ja auch in der Ausbildung nach innen weitergeben müssen. Und wie weit ist denn die, ich kann mich jetzt nicht erinnern, dass der Bundeswehr jemals erfolgreich vorgeworfen werden konnte, dass sie jetzt so ein Nazi-Hort geworden sind, wo Leute, die Bock auf Schießen und Ballern haben, ein schönes Zuhause haben? Insofern kann man doch schon auch von einem gewissen Erfolg sprechen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also das verbindet sich ja mit den Begriffen Staatsbürger in Uniformen und innere Führung. Und natürlich gab es gerade in den Anfangszeiten Leute, die aus alten Zeiten aus der Wehrmacht stammten und teilweise sicherlich auch versucht haben, solches Gedanken gut mitzubringen. Das hat nicht Fuß gefasst. Also die Bundeswehr behauptet immer, sie sei die demokratischste Armee, die Deutschland je gehabt habe. Und da würde ich ihr auch nicht widersprechen an der Stelle.
Und durch welche strukturellen Maßnahmen ist das gelungen? Also was hat dazu beigetragen, dass das auch funktionieren konnte?
Also ich denke dieses Leitbild vom Staatsbürger in Uniform. Also jetzt müssen wir mal zwei Dinge trennen vielleicht. Wenn man sowas sagt, kriegt man dann schnell zu hören, naja gut, aber der Ton war natürlich weiterhin kommissköpfig bis dorthin aus und so weiter. Gut, das ist dann sozusagen die praktische Seite von Militär. Aber wenn wir auf die politischen Grundlagen gucken, eine Armee, die auf die Verfassung vereidigt ist, die also auch ganz dezidiert dazu geschaffen wurde, die Grundwerte zu verteidigen. Das ist schon ein ganz anderer Ansatz.
Als andere Armeen?
Als deutsche Armeen davor. Das auf jeden Fall. Man muss es ja immer vor dem Hintergrund der deutschen Geschichte sehen. Und das mit den anderen Armeen, gerade unsere europäischen Nachbarn, vor allem Frankreich und Großbritannien, haben natürlich ein ganz anderes und vor allem auch ein ungebrochenes Verhältnis zu Militär, zu militärischen Einsätzen, zu militärischem Agieren überhaupt. Also dieser Bruch, den es in der deutschen Geschichte Gott sei Dank gab, den gibt es in den Ländern nicht. Weil da ist Militär sehr selbstverständlich auch ein Mittel der Außenpolitik. Gerade wenn wir uns die Franzosen angucken, die keine Probleme haben, irgendwo in Afrika zu intervenieren.
Wie zum Beispiel jetzt in Libyen?
Zum Beispiel, ja. Libyen wäre so ein Beispiel. Es ist nicht klassisches französisches Interessengebiet, aber es gab ja genügend andere Beispiele. Briten in Sierra Leone, Franzosen im Schatt und Zentralafrikanische Republik und Ähnliches. Was aus deutscher Sicht für Deutschland undenkbar ist.
Mittlerweile?
Ja, also seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg, seitdem ist die Bundesrepublik.
Aber, ähm... Könntest du sagen, wie es der Bundeswehr gelungen ist? Also, ich meine, strukturell, man könnte ja sagen, so eine Militärstruktur, hierarchisch, Kommandobefehle etc. ist nicht unbedingt jetzt der ideale Ort, um solche Verhaltensweisen zu gebären. Was hat denn die Bundeswehr anders getan? Ausbildungstechnisch oder so? Ich war ja nicht bei der Bundeswehr, keine Ahnung.
Ich denke, sie hat versucht, und ich kann das ja nur als außenstehender Beobachter beurteilen, sie hat versucht, schon dieses andere politische Verständnis von Streitkräften auch bei der Ausbildung ihrer Soldaten mit einzubringen. Also wenn ich so daran denke, dass Offiziere inzwischen auf jeden Fall studieren müssen. Also wenn man Offizier werden will, muss man studieren. Und das an Hochschulen, natürlich es gibt auch diese beiden Bundeswehr-Hochschulen in München und in Hamburg, wo aber das Studium selber eigentlich eine zivile Angelegenheit ist. Also es ist nicht so, die gehen auf eine Militärakademie und lernen Krieg und sonst nicht viel, sondern es ist eigentlich eher umgekehrt.
Was studieren denn die Offiziere so?
Alles Mögliche, von Pädagogik über Maschinenbau bis zu Wirtschaftswissenschaften. Also eigentlich alles, was man auch im zivilen Leben studieren würde.
Und kommt das dann überhaupt für die noch zum Einsatz?
Na ja, sie sagen oder ihr Beruf ist Soldat zu sein. Aber mit diesem Ausbildungshintergrund, dass sie Diplom-Pädagoge sind zum Beispiel. Also ich kenne einen, der ist Diplom-Pädagoge und bringt das dann immer auf die leicht witzig gemeinte Formel ich bin bewaffneter Kindergärtner. Und das ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben.
Ja, aber es ist nicht so, dass er jetzt pädagogische Kenntnisse nicht zur Einsatz bringen könnte.
Nein, natürlich nicht. Natürlich muss man auch, wenn man so einen Laden managt und wenn man, weiß ich nicht, paar hundert Leute befehligt, muss man natürlich trotzdem auch vielleicht eine Ahnung haben, wie man mit diesen Leuten umgeht. Also diese Vorstellung mit Befehl und Gehorsam, einer sagt und alle machen, ist natürlich bei jeder Großorganisation ein bisschen komplizierter. Auch in einer normalen Firma ist es, es heißt zwar nicht Befehl und Gehorsam, aber ein Chef ordnet an und andere führen das aus. Und auch da spielt schon sehr stark eine Rolle, wie er mit den Leuten umgeht.
Dieses Hamsegedient, das war lange, lange Zeit, war es ja so, dass wenn man nicht zur Bundeswehr gegangen ist, also ich habe das Gefühl, so in meiner Generation lief das so langsam aus. Aber man merkte noch, dass das schon da war. Leute, die nicht zur Bundeswehr gehen, haben ja nichts, wie soll ich sagen, nicht gelernt, ich interpretiere es eher als einen Wunsch der Etablierten, dass sie lernen, sich in solche Führungsstrukturen einzuordnen und mal hier richtig gelebt zu haben, von unten nach oben, damit sie wissen, wie der Hase läuft, auch im richtigen Leben. Und das ist natürlich dann auch etwas, was in den 80er Jahren kräftig unter die Räder gekommen ist, so als Gesellschaftsbild. Jetzt ist durch diesen, wie wir schon angedeutet haben, durch dieses Somalia-Ding und die ganzen anderen Einsätze 20 Jahre vergangen. Und jetzt haben wir ja schon wieder einen weiteren Wandel, wo ja auch die Bundeswehr auf einmal nicht mehr die Wehrpflicht hat, um ihr neues Personal zuzutreiben, sondern erstmalig darauf angewiesen ist, freiwillig Leute aufzunehmen. Das ist ja lange lange lange Zeit immer wieder diskutiert worden. Jetzt ist es umgesetzt worden, durch den besonders populären auch nicht mehr Verteidigungsminister, Herrn Gutenberg. Und was hat sich das eigentlich schon immer abgezeichnet? Ist das so der Weg, den die Bundeswehr eigentlich auch selber gehen wollte? Oder hat hier jetzt etwas stattgefunden, was gegen den Wunsch der Bundeswehr läuft?
Ja, es war an einer Stelle gegen den Wunsch der Bundeswehr. Und zwar an der Stelle, du hast gesagt, ihn die Leute zuzutreiben. Also im Grunde genommen, sie hatten auf eine recht komode Art den potenziellen Nachwuchs schon mal zur Begutachtung da. Also die Leute kamen, oder die jungen Männer, das waren ja nur Männer, das muss man ja auch noch berücksichtigen, die kamen also zwangsweise. Und ein Großteil derjenigen, die sich länger verpflichtet haben als Zeitsoldat oder als Berufssoldat, kamen aus diesem Kreis der Wehrpflichtigen. Weil die waren schon mal dabei, die fanden das dann gut und dann waren sie da. Und wenn man die nicht so über diese Weise bekommen hätte, und das ist das Problem, was die Bundeswehr jetzt hat, muss man ja irgendwie an die Leute rankommen, die man begeistern will, die man langfristig gewinnen will. Und auf Seiten der Bundeswehr, das geben auch Generalen zu, wenn man mit ihnen spricht, war das letztendlich aus Militärsicht das letzte noch verbliebene Argument für die Wehrpflicht. Alles andere, ein Volk steht auf in Waffen, wenn der Feind kommt, das hat sich erledigt. Das ist nichts mehr, womit man in absehbarer Zeit rechnen muss. Das heißt, die Professionalisierung der Armee war ja eigentlich schon längst überfällig. Also es ist ja schon seit Jahren so, in die Auslandseinsätze wurden keine Wehrpflichtigen mitgenommen. Das war von vornherein ausgeschlossen. Das war keine gesetzliche Grundlage, aber das war sozusagen eine Vereinbarung oder eine Festlegung. Sondern es ging nur die hin, die freiwillig verlängert haben. Da gab es dann diese freiwillig längere Wehrdienstleistenden, die bis zu 23 Monate aufstocken konnten. Und die gingen und gehen, das ist halt auch nicht anders, in die Auslandseinsätze. Aber der normale Wehrpflichtige mit seinen neun Monaten über lange Zeit, oder am Ende waren es ja nur noch sechs Monate, der hat nie den Kosovo oder Afghanistan gesehen. Und man braucht bei solchen Einsätzen ja auch Leute, die ein gewisses Ausbildungsniveau haben, die man darauf vorbereitet hat auf die Situation, auf Gefährdungen, auf den Umgang mit Gefahren, auf das soldatische Handwerk.
Bist du sicher, dass es da keine Ausnahmen gab? Ich meine mich gerade, jemanden erinnern zu können, der auch im Kosovo war, aber mir ist jetzt sein Status ehrlich gesagt nicht ganz klar. Vielleicht war er doch schon über den Grundwehr-Einsatz hinaus.
Also das kann eigentlich nicht sein.
Wenn es nicht sein kann, dann ist es wahrscheinlich nicht so. Aber schon, wenn man einmal nach der Grundwehrdienst gesagt hat, ich bleibe jetzt hier einfach noch ein paar Jahre länger, dann wurde einem aber auch unter Umständen gesagt, dass man da hingehen muss.
Nicht nur unter Umständen, das war schon klar. Also es war bei allen klar, die über den Grundwehrdienst hinaus verlängert haben, dass sie damit auch unterschrieben haben, ich bin bereit, in einen Auslandseinsatz zu gehen.
Und man kann dann auch gar nicht mehr nein sagen?
Man kann dann auch nicht mehr nein sagen. Gut, es gibt dann gesundheitliche Probleme vielleicht, oder psychologische oder generelle Ausschlussgründe, die dazu führen, dass jemand nicht nach Afghanistan oder in Kosovo geschickt werden kann. Aber die grundsätzliche Bereitschaft war mit dieser Längerverpflichtung erklärt. Das ist ja heute so mit den freiwillig Wehrdienstleistenden, wie es heißt, die können ja auch bis zu 23 Monate dienen. Und jeder, der sich für länger als ein Jahr verpflichtet, erklärt damit automatisch seine Bereitschaft, in Auslandseinsatz zu gehen.
Mal bleiben wir noch mal kurz bei der Wehrpflicht und was der Wegfall jetzt so für Auswirkungen ist. Ich meine, bei anderen Ländern gibt es im europäischen Raum noch Wehrpflicht-Armeen?
Es gibt noch ein paar.
Bei wem ist das noch so?
Bei den osteuropäischen Nachbarn. Bei Polen bin ich mir jetzt nicht sicher. Ich meine ja, baltische Länder.
Aber in Westeuropa überhaupt nicht?
Nein, in Westeuropa im Prinzip nicht mehr. Die haben alle gesagt, das ist kein Instrument, das wir noch brauchen. Die USA ja schon sehr lange übrigens. Nach dem Vietnamkrieg haben die das ja bereits abgeschafft.
Was ja auch immer so ein Argument ist, ist, ich habe die politische Diskussion um dieses Für und Wider mit Wehrpflicht immer nur sehr am Rande verfolgt. Aber was mir immer so hängen blieb oder was ich aus eigener Betrachtung auch immer gesehen habe oder meinte gesehen zu haben, ist in dem Moment, wo man eben sagt, okay, wir sieben jetzt mal aus allen. Und wir rufen vielleicht nicht jeden ein, aber wir haben uns zumindest mal alle mal angeschaut und so. Und dann gibt es ja eben genau diesen Fall, Leute erwärmen sich dafür, die das nie so gedacht haben. Und bei anderen ist es vielleicht auch genau andersrum, die immer davon geträumt haben, Soldat zu sein. Und kommen, waren sie da, dachten sie sich, oh Gott, das ist ja auch, das führt ja dann sozusagen auch erst mal so zu so einer Motivationsmischung, die der Bundeswehr eigentlich nur sehr recht sein kann, dass Leute auf einmal so ihr Herz für etwas entdecken, die dann auch wirklich gerne da sind, die dann vielleicht so jetzt nie den Weg finden würden. Auf der anderen Seite frage ich mich natürlich auch, wer entscheidet sich jetzt freiwillig für die Bundeswehr? Ist das jetzt nicht eigentlich so salopp gesagt, dass mehr der Perspektivlosen, die für sich im Arbeitsmarkt oder sonst irgendwie da keine Zukunft mehr sehen und sagen, ach dann gehe ich mal zur Bundeswehr, die nehmen jeden?
Also die These gibt es natürlich. Es gibt ja den Münchner Professor Wolfson, der von einer Prekarisierung und einer Verostung der Bundeswehr spricht. Also ganz klar die These in den Öden des Ostens, wo die Arbeitslosigkeit besonders hoch ist, meldet man sich dann gerne zur Bundeswehr. Ob das wirklich so schlimm kommt, weiß ich nicht. Kann auch im Moment glaube ich keiner sagen.
Aber die Diskussion gibt es schon.
Die Diskussion gibt es schon, auf jeden Fall. Man weiß natürlich auch aus anderen Ländern, dass es einen Zusammenhang gibt zwischen der Situation am Arbeitsmarkt und der Bereitschaft zum Militär zu gehen. Wenn wir uns das in den USA angucken, da gibt es ganze Landstriche, irgendwo in den Appalachen oder in West-Virginia, wo überproportional viele Leute sich dann zum Militärdienst melden, weil es gibt Geld, es gibt unter Umständen Möglichkeit für ein Studium, es gibt einfach Lebensperspektiven, die sie sonst nicht haben. Gut, das muss man einpreisen, das ist so. Wie stark sich das in Deutschland auswirken wird, ist, glaube ich, noch ein bisschen zu früh, das zu sagen. Und andersrum übrigens, die nehmen jeden, stimmt ja auch nicht. Sondern es gibt ja schon Auswahlkriterien, die natürlich umso stringenter und strenger sind, je längerfristig oder je höher die Stellung ist, die man anstrebt. Also für einen Offizier gibt es ganz festgelegte, klare Voraussetzungen, die einer mitbringen muss. Es gibt physische Anforderungen natürlich. Also nach dem Motto, wer seine Liegestütze und Klimmzüge nicht schafft, der braucht auch gar nicht erst zu klopfen. Das ist übrigens ein ganz, ganz interessanter Ansatz, wenn man sich die Nachwuchswerbung anderer Länder anguckt. Wie gesagt, die Briten oder die Franzosen haben ein deutlich anderes, ungebrochenes Verhältnis zum Militär. Es gibt zum Beispiel einen berühmten Werbespot der Royal Marines in Großbritannien, wo die Leute wirklich durch richtig übel, wie man sich das vorstellt, Situationen gescheucht werden. Also unter Wasser und durch den Schlamm und Hochaufenturm und Stacheldraht. Also all diese Vorstellungen, die man da hat. Und dann wird immer eingeblendet, ist dir das zu viel? Denk gar nicht erst dran, dich zu bewerben. You don't even think about applying. Das wollte ich nur ein bisschen zur Illustration. Die nehmen jeden, das ist einfach eine falsche Ansicht.
Deutsche Bundeswehr-Werbung ist aber ein bisschen anders. Das ist mehr so... Ich weiß, ich habe jetzt nicht so viel gesehen, aber ich habe immer das Gefühl, das hat mehr so mit Ausbildungsperspektiven und so weiter.
Also nach dem Motto, du kannst bei uns Koch oder Kfz-Mechaniker werden. Ja, so ist das und ich finde das traurig. Also das sage ich denen ja auch ab und zu. Ich finde das einfach deswegen traurig, weil die den Leuten auch ein falsches Bild vorgaukeln. Also man muss den Leuten sagen, du kannst zwar bei uns Kfz-Mechaniker werden, aber du kommst nicht zu uns in erster Linie, weil du Kfz-Mechaniker werden kannst oder willst. Sondern du wirst Kfz-Mechaniker dann in Kundus. Und da deine Arbeit vielleicht machen. Oder wenn du in der Lage bist, ein Auto zu reparieren, bedeutet das, dass du irgendwo auf einer staubigen Landstraße in Afghanistan, wo du jeden Moment beschossen werden kannst, ein liegengebliebenes Fahrzeug wieder flott machst. Ich finde, das muss man den Leuten eigentlich auch direkt dazu sagen. Also diese Nachwuchswerbung, die die Bundeswehr jetzt macht, ist mir schon ein bisschen zu sehr. Och, wie schön hier können sie Karriere machen.
Aber jetzt so ein Stunt-Video zu drehen, wenn man irgendwie nervös in Afghanistan steht und irgendwie unter Beschuss den Wagen repariert, wäre jetzt auch nicht gerade unbedingt besonders einladend, oder?
Nö, gut, es gibt ja zwischen diesen beiden Extremen vielleicht noch gewisse Zwischentöne, könnte man sich ja denken. Nein, aber mir geht es einfach darum, ich finde, man muss den Leuten schon sagen, wenn du zur Bundeswehr gehen willst, erstens, primär bist du Soldat, und zweitens bist du dann Koch, Kraftfahrer, Kfz-Mechaniker, was auch immer.
Warum wolltest du denn nicht hin?
Ach, jetzt wirst du aber sehr persönlich. Ich habe ja auch mal Theologie studiert, und du fragst mich auch nicht, warum ich Theologie studiert habe.
Ich auch noch. Da frag ich auch gerne noch mal nach.
Das war damals meine persönliche Entscheidung. Übrigens auch noch mit Prüfungskommission. Das war noch die Prüfungskommission beim Kreiswehrersatzamt, wo ich das rechtfertigen musste.
Also wir reden ja auch von einer Zeit, wo man sich eben aktiv bemühen musste. Man musste sagen, ich will Zivildienst machen, wenn man jetzt nicht total verweigert. Man hatte nicht einfach die Ich-nimm-das-oder-ich-nimm-das-Option. Man musste richtig begründen, warum man nicht hin will. Das ist ja schon noch mal eine andere Situation. Das muss man schon noch mal klar machen.
Na gut, das ist jetzt 30 Jahre her.
Gut, ich kann das nachvollziehen. Ich hatte jetzt mangels der richtigen Staatsbürgerschaft stand ich nicht vor der Wahl. Würde dich das jetzt mit deiner ganzen Bundeswehr-Erfahrung mehr interessieren?
Nee, ich weiß es nicht. Wenn wir jetzt schon persönlich werden, die Bundeswehr bietet ja an sogenannte Wehrübungen für zivile Führungskräfte. Das heißt, da werden dann Manager aus verschiedenen Bereichen, aber auch Journalisten eingeladen. Wir stecken euch zwei Wochen in Uniform und ihr guckt euch zwei Wochen mal an, wie das bei der Bundeswehr eigentlich ist. Da kriegt man so einen temporären Dienstgrad, wird man oberleutnant auf Zeit oder so etwas für die zwei Wochen.
Ist das so die Bundeswehr-Variante von Weltraum-Tourismus sozusagen?
Nein, das ist die Bundeswehr-Variante von gehobenem Schnupperpraktikum. Da werde ich auch ab und zu gefragt, willst du das nicht auch machen? Und ich sage, das geht nicht. Dann gucken mich alle groß an und ich bin ein erkenner Kriegsdienstverweiger. Ja, das können sie doch zurücknehmen. Dann sage ich, ich werde einen Teufel tun. Ich werde einen Teufel tun, diese Entscheidung vor 30 Jahren einfach aus dem Grund zurückzunehmen.
Was darf man denn dann machen bei diesem Schnupperpraktikum? Richtig einmal Grundausbildung leid?
Ja, sehr leid, weil einfach durch den Zeitrahmen, zwei Wochen ist ja nicht so viel. Aber man kriegt dann so eine geile Tour inklusive Schießen.
Kennst du jemanden, der das mal gemacht hat?
Ich kenne einige, die das mal gemacht haben. Ich finde die Idee so schlecht nicht, Leuten aus der Wirtschaft mal zu zeigen. Im Praktikum ist vielleicht der falsche Begriff, aber dass Leute sich mal in anderen Bereichen umtun. Warum sollen sich nicht mal Manager auch bei der Bundeswehr umtun? Um zu wissen, was läuft da eigentlich. Gerade weil es ja zunehmend jetzt durch die Altersstaffelung Leute gibt, die nie bei der Bundeswehr waren. Das wird ja natürlich noch mehr sein. Also vor 20, 30 Jahren hat ein Großteil der Männer halt gedient, wie das hieß. Und das wurden immer weniger und demnächst sind es extrem wenig. Die haben natürlich ein Bild von der Bundeswehr, was vielleicht nicht unbedingt stimmt. Und deswegen finde ich das nicht schlecht.
Welches Bild muss man sich denn jetzt machen von der Bundeswehr? Ich meine, jetzt hatten wir 20 Jahre des Wandels befördert, vor allem durch die weltpolitische Lage. Das immer wieder wohl diskutierte geänderte Sicherheitsprofil oder wie nennt man das? Sicherheitslage hat sich geändert. Ich meine, es ändert sich sowieso immer am laufenden Meter irgendetwas. Aber seitdem ist ja auch eine Menge passiert. Somalia ist ja dann nicht der einzige Auslandseinsatz gewesen. Und war ja auch eher so ein bisschen erstmal nur so ein, ja wie soll ich das sagen, klingt so ein bisschen wie so eine generelle, wir sind jetzt einfach mal dabei, weil wir uns das nicht mehr leisten können, auf internationaler Bühne nicht mehr dabei zu sein.
Ja, also dazu passt ja sehr gut. Ich stand ja in Belletvane auf der Rollbahn, damals im Mai 1993, als die ersten deutschen Soldaten einflogen. Und dann kletterten die aus ihrem Flugzeug. Und einer, nach meiner Erinnerung war es der General, der dabei war, sagte den denkwürdigen Satz, wir sind wieder in der Familie. Ja, der Frage würde selbst wahrnehmen. Wenn man so sieht, internationale Kontakte gab es natürlich immer. Und dann saß man da mit seinen britischen Kameraden irgendwo bei Bielefeld rum. Und die sagten, übrigens nächste Woche gehen wir nach Afrika oder so. Und die sagten, schön, wir sind auf Übung an der Elbe. Ich übertreibe jetzt nur mal so ein bisschen. Das hat natürlich auch so ein bisschen die Selbstwahrnehmung geprägt.
Also auch so ein bisschen so, wir würden eigentlich auch ganz gerne mal ein bisschen dabei sein.
Ja, das spielt unterschwellig natürlich eine Rolle. Klar, macht ja keinen Sinn, das zu leugnen auf jeden Fall. Aber wie du schon sagst, seitdem hat sich natürlich die ganze weltpolitische Lage ziemlich geändert und auch die Erwartungen an die Deutschen haben sich geändert. Also bis zum Fall der Mauer haben, glaube ich, alle Verbündeten klaglos, problemlos akzeptiert ihr Deutschen. Ihr sitzt halt in Deutschland an der Nahtstelle dieser beiden Blöcke. Und wenn es da den großen Vaterländischen Krieg gibt, dann seid ihr mittendrin. Den wird es nun nicht mehr geben. Und dann kommen die Briten, die Franzosen, um nur die beiden großen europäischen Verbündeten zu nennen und sagen, Moment mal, ihr seid doch nicht gerade eine richtig arme Nation, im Vergleich mit den Briten, ich glaube, die sagen das. Also ihr seid eigentlich gerade arme Nation. Ihr habt Streitkräfte, für die ihr viel Geld ausgebt und die auch Leistungen, was leisten können, die zu was fähig sind. Und warum drückt ihr euch jetzt, wenn es um bestimmte internationale Einsätze geht? Also ich habe das bei Libyen übrigens gehört, jetzt können wir über Libyen auch noch gesondert reden, weil da spielen einfach auch politische Gründe eine Rolle. Aber ich habe von einem recht hochrangigen britischen Offiziellen im privaten Gespräch die Klage gehört, die deutsche Luftwaffe hätte doch all das, was wir in Libyen brauchen. Und ihr lasst uns da im Stich. Es ist jetzt keine Begründung für einen Einsatz, aber es zeigt einfach, wie auch aus dem Ausland auf Deutschland geschaut wird.
Ja, eine lange Zeit hat man dann immer so, haben die Politiker dann immer so, aber hier in unserer Verfassung steht doch, wir dürfen nicht.
Ja, das ist auch eine interessante Sache. Machen sich ja die meisten Leute auch nicht bewusst. Also in der Verfassung steht in der Tat, der Bund stellt Streitkräfte zur Verteidigung auf, im Artikel 87 des Grundgesetzes. Und außer zur Verteidigung dürfen diese Streitkräfte nur eingesetzt werden, so weit es das Grundgesetz ausdrücklich zulässt. Daraus schließen jetzt einige, alles, was da im Afghanistan passiert oder so, ist ja ein grundgesetzwidriger Krieg, weil das erlaubt die Verfassung ja nicht. Jetzt gibt es ja den Umweg, der ist in der Tat ein Umweg, aber die Definition im Artikel 24 des Grundgesetzes, dass sich nämlich Deutschland Systemen kollektiver Sicherheit anschließen kann. Also, die NATO, natürlich in erster Stelle, die Vereinten Nationen, zunehmend aber auch die EU. Und wenn wir uns Einsätze der Bundeswehr anschauen, das sind ja nie Einsätze der Deutschen alleine, sondern es sind immer ausschließlich Einsätze, die im Rahmen eines solchen Bündnisses passieren. Also Afghanistan ist ein NATO-Einsatz zum Beispiel. Auch noch dazu UN mandatiert, also da greifen gleich zwei solcher Punkte. Kosovo ist inzwischen ein UN-mandatierter Einsatz. Das war ja ein NATO-Einsatz am Anfang. Auch das ist dann nochmal eine besondere Problematik. Aber worauf ich hinaus will, ist, es ist ja in keinem Fall so, dass die Bundesregierung beschließt, mit Zustimmung des Bundestages, deutsche Soldaten marschieren jetzt irgendwo hin. Sondern es geht dem immer eine Entscheidung in einem dieser Bündnisse voraus. Oder ein Auftrag bzw. ein Mandat der UN.
Und in Libyen war aber Deutschland auch Teil dieser Entscheidung?
In der NATO, ja.
In der NATO? Ich spreche jetzt die eigentlichen UN-Entscheidungen an, für die Deutschen sich enthalten haben.
Das ist eine dieser ein bisschen komplizierter zu erklären und schwer nachzuvollziehenen Entscheidungen. Also im UN-Sicherheitsrat hat Deutschland kein ständiges Mitglied, sondern nur temporär jetzt Mitglied gesagt. Wir tragen diese Entscheidung des Sicherheitsrats zu Libyen nicht mit und enthalten uns. Es war de facto unerheblich, weil Deutschland ja kein Veto-Recht hat. Also auch wenn die Nein gesagt hätten, die Mehrheitsentscheidung hätte trotzdem, nur die großen fünf können das ja blockieren, hat sich Deutschland enthalten, was deswegen für Aufsehen gesorgt hat, weil wenn sich Russland enthält oder China, ist das quasi eine Zustimmung, weil sie es nicht blockieren. Wenn die Deutschen sich enthalten in so einer Situation und damit gegen den Rest ihrer Verbündeten stehen, dann ist es quasi eine Ablehnung, auch wenn es nicht de facto die Möglichkeit hat. Dann aber, und das sagen wir ja dann lieber nicht ganz so laut, dann hat ja die NATO beschlossen, diese Aktion, diese Operation zu übernehmen. Erst eine Seeblockade zur Findung von Waffenschmuggel und dann diese Luftangriffe. Und diese Entscheidung der NATO konnte nur stande kommen mit deutscher Zustimmung, weil in der NATO herrscht das Konsensprinzip. Wenn also irgendein NATO-Partner, unser heißen ganz kleiner wie Luxemburg, sagt nein, dann findet das nicht statt. Und die ganzen Luftangriffe auf Libyen sind im Grunde genommen mit einem deutschen Ja versehen worden. Auch wenn die Deutschen gesagt haben, nein, wir machen natürlich nicht mit.
Warum haben die sich überhaupt da so? Ich meine, was steckt dahinter?
Hier hinter was jetzt? Der Entscheidung im Sicherheitsrat, der Entscheidung im NATO-Rat, der Entscheidung, nicht teilzunehmen. Es ist eine ziemliche Gemengelage.
Ja, ich meine, dieses sich enthalten, das heißt ja im Prinzip von vornherein, naja, wir tun jetzt mal so, als würden wir es nicht verhindern, aber wir wollen nicht mitschießen.
Ja, das scheint der Grund dahinter gewesen zu sein. Ob das so sinnvoll war, weil das auch ziemlich viel Vertrauen bei befreundeten Nationen aufs Spiel gesetzt hat oder immer noch aufs Spiel setzt, ist ja dann eine ganz andere Frage.
Diese ganzen Auslandseinsätze finde ich eigentlich sehr interessant. Vielleicht spulen wir noch mal zurück in der Zeit. Somalia war ja dann als Einsatz als solcher eine ziemliche Pleite. Die Amerikaner sind da irgendwie…
sind recht zügig rausgegangen und die Deutschen dann auch sehr, sehr zügig, was natürlich damit zusammenhängt und daran hat sich ja in den letzten 20 Jahren nichts geändert. Das, abgesehen von sehr kleinen Operationen, die Europäer ohne die technische, materielle Unterstützung der Amerikaner zu vielen Dingen einfach nicht in der Lage sind.
Das heißt, die Amerikaner haben auch meistens immer auch die Leitung übernommen dieser Einsätze?
Nee, das kann man so nicht zwingend sagen. Schauen wir uns jetzt in Kosovo zum Beispiel an, da ist jetzt seit einem Jahr ein deutscher Kommandeur und der nächste Kommandeur wird auch wieder ein deutscher sein. Das ist dann auch mal eine Sondesituation. Aber da unterstehen amerikanische Soldaten deutschen Befehl oder einem deutschen NATO-Kommandeur. Und da gibt es ähnliche Fälle. Aber de facto ist es einfach so, dass es Bereiche gibt, wenn die Amerikaner nicht ihr Material und ihre Manpower da reinbringen, völlig egal, wer den Befehl hat. Wenn die sagen, wir ziehen diese Manpower und das Material raus, dann haben die anderen ein Problem. Ein typisches Beispiel ist derzeit Afghanistan übrigens. Der ganze Einsatz in Nordafghanistan funktioniert nur, weil die Amerikaner im vergangenen Jahr nicht nur massiv Truppen reingebracht haben. Das ist auch ein Teil. Sie haben aber ein ganz wichtiges, wie heißt es im NATO-Slang, Asset reingebracht, nämlich Hubschrauber. Also vorher, die Deutschen und die Norweger, glaube ich, zusammen vielleicht acht Hubschrauber hatten, haben die Amerikaner jetzt 50 Hubschrauber. Das ist ein kleiner Unterschied. Oder ganz entscheidend, in Nordafghanistan haben die Amerikaner allein 15 Rettungshubschrauber für Verwundete stationiert. Und wenn es diese 15 Rettungshubschrauber nicht gäbe, könnten die Deutschen und die anderen Nationen ganz viele Dinge nicht mehr machen. Weil der Anspruch gilt, jeder Soldat muss innerhalb einer bestimmten Zeit so und so schnell in ein Lazarett, also ins Krankenhaus, gebracht werden können. Und wenn das nicht geht, dann passiert halt nichts.
Und gibt es diese Hubschrauber nicht oder gibt es die nur nicht da?
Jetzt bei den Europäern oder bei den Deutschen?
Also haben die Deutschen nicht die Kapazitäten? Also wenn sie wollten, könnten sie gar nicht so viele da hinkriegen, weil so viele nicht existieren?
So ungefähr, ja. Also sie haben zwar relativ viele Hubschrauber, aber das ist ja auch noch so eine Erbe von langem kalten Krieg. Die Deutschen haben sich natürlich einen irren Gerätepark aufgebaut, der auf mitteleuropäisches Klima und mitteleuropäische Verhältnisse ausgerichtet ist. Also Hubschrauber, die in der Lüneburger Heide wunderbar funktionieren, also in der norddeutschen Tiefebene, wo der Krieg erwartet wurde, die allerdings für ein Land mit der Höhe, den Temperaturen und den Umweltbedingungen wie Afghanistan einfach nicht gebaut sind. Und da braucht man dann anderes Material. Das kostet A ein Schweinegeld und B dauert das eine ganze Weile, bis es da ist. Der Hubschrauber, der nächstes Jahr in Einsatz kommen soll, heißt NH90. 90 erinnert an eine Jahreszahl.
Ich erinnere mich an den Jäger 90.
Ja, bei dem war es das gleiche. Das ist ja abgeleitet von der Dekade der 1990er Jahre. Und das ist 20 Jahre her.
Ich würde mich trotzdem gerne noch mal ein bisschen in diese Auslandseinsätze reinklinken und was die sozusagen bewirkt haben. Also nach Somalia, was kam dann als nächstes? War das schon der Kosovo, war das schon der Einsatz?
Nein, nein, erst kam Bosnien.
Das war ja insofern eine besondere Situation, als dass auf einmal der Konflikt der tatsächlich Europa war.
Ja, es war für die Deutschen eine doppels schwierige Situation, der Konflikt Europa und natürlich ein Flüchtlingsstrom auch nach Deutschland, der sehr viel zu dem Sinneswandel oder zu der Bereitschaft zu diesem Einsatz beigetragen hat. Und natürlich auch ein politischer Sinneswandel, weil vorher galt so ein bisschen, unausgesprochen die Maxime, deutsche Soldaten gehen nirgendwo hin, wo die Wehrmacht im Zweiten Weltkrieg war und sicherlich auch sehr ungute Erinnerungen hinterlassen hat. Und das galt natürlich gerade für den Balkan. Es gibt da sehr, sehr üble Erinnerungen.
Ja, auch der Start des Ersten Weltkrieges.
Ja gut, so weit zurück war es noch nicht mal, sondern es ging schon um das Wüten deutscher Soldaten, Stichwort Partisanenbekämpfung auf dem Balkan. Das hat, glaube ich, mehr geprägt. Ich glaube, das Erbe des Ersten Weltkrieges und KOK-Monarchie und all diese Dinge, das ist, glaube ich, zu lang zurück, als dass das da noch eine konkrete Rolle gespielt hätte. Aber die Frage war, sind deutsche Soldaten auf dem Balkan Teil des Problems oder Teil der Lösung? Und irgendwann kam die Politik zu der Ansicht, sie seien Teil der Lösung. Und dann begann es relativ vorsichtig, zunächst nur mit...
Weil ja im Prinzip das andere böse Wort ins Spiel kam, nämlich der Völkermord, wo natürlich die Deutschen auf eine andere Art und Weise dann wiederum eine Verpflichtung gesehen haben, und dann dreht sich das dann auf einmal alles um.
Ja, das kam nach Srebrenica. Und das ist übrigens interessant, wenn man auf einen anderen europäischen Nachbarn guckt, auf die Holländer, deren Verhältnis zu Auslandseinsätzen sich nach Srebrenica sehr stark geändert hat. Einfach aus dem Bewusstsein oder dem Eingeständnis, in Srebrenica ist es richtig schiefgelaufen, weil die niederländischen Soldaten sind ja im Grunde genommen vorgeführt worden. Es gibt ja diese berühmten Bilder, wie der niederländische Kommandeur mit Mladic anstößt. Also wo sie sagen, es gibt auch eine Verpflichtung. Also Soldaten sind nicht nur, wir müssen andersrum formulieren, Auslandseinsätze oder Missionen können auch eine Verpflichtung sein, die eine Nation hat.
Und so sehen das die Holländer jetzt so? Oder jetzt sehen sie es nicht mehr so?
Also wenn man sieht, in welchem Maße die Holländer sich engagiert haben in Auslandseinsätzen, dann sehen wir es so. Inzwischen ist auch da ein bisschen eine Veränderung, die aber auch sehr stark mit finanziellen Gründen zu tun hat, weil es kostet halt einfach ein Schweinegeld.
Und gut, die Deutschen haben sich dann entschlossen, sich dem Einsatz anzuschließen bei einer sehr breiten und heftigen Diskussion in Deutschland über Kriegstreibertum und jetzt führt man einen Angriffskrieg. Das war ja sozusagen das Wort der Opposition. Wie hast du das gesehen? Warst du da auch vor Ort?
Ich war nicht in Sarajevo zu der Zeit, als es eine reine Blauhelmmission ohne deutsche Beteiligung war, sondern ich war erst später da. Ich habe sehr viel auch mit Kollegen, mit Freunden geredet, die auch in der heißen Zeit in Sarajevo waren. Ich habe das immer so empfunden, dass natürlich, was heißt natürlich, dass der Einsatz von Streitkräften auch dazu dienen kann und muss, Dinge zu verhindern, also Gewalt von anderen abzuwenden. Und so habe ich das bei diesem ersten Balkaneinsatz auf jeden Fall empfunden.
Und so war auch das Selbstverständnis der Bundeswehr?
Ja, die Bundeswehr ist ja auch sehr behutsam und gar nicht mit Kampftruppen. Und das erste, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, war ein Feldlazarett bei Trogier, was sie eingerichtet hatten.
Das war wieder gutes Tun.
Das war wieder gutes Tun und Nachschub und eigentlich nicht mit der Waffe in der Hand irgendwo reingehen, sondern wir unterstützen die Guten. Was sich ja dann in dem sogenannten Kosovo-Krieg sehr drastisch geändert hat. Also das ist übrigens eine, böse ausgedrückt würde ich sagen, Meisterpropaganda-Leistung von Rot-Grün gewesen, dass sie relativ schnell vergessen machen konnten, dass es einen Krieg auf zumindest wackeliger völkerrechtlicher Grundlage gab, wo erstmals deutsche Soldaten gezielt ihre Waffen eingesetzt haben.
Das war dann das erste Mal.
Ja, also nicht in Selbstverteidigung oder so, sondern wirklich gezielt angegriffen haben. Das war ja diese Kosovo-Air-Campaign, wie die NATO sagen würde. Also es wurden ja Ziele in Serbien angegriffen, um zu erreichen, dass Serbien seine militärischen Aktionen im Kosovo einstellt. Also es gab ja Luftangriffe auf Ziele, die hunderte Kilometer vom Kosovo entfernt waren. Eine serbische Freundin von mir brachte das mal auf die Formel. Das ist so, als wenn in Bayern ein Volksaufstand wäre. Und um darauf einzuwirken, wird Hamburg bombardiert. Das war es de facto. Und die Deutschen haben ja, auch wenn die Zahlen nicht offiziell bestätigt wurden, etwa 250 Raketen auf Radarstellung abgefeuert.
Ich meine, Teil moderner Kriegsführung ist natürlich die Kommunikation zerstören. Ist das nicht eine zwangsläufige Folge aus der militärischen Logik?
Ja, sicher. Ich sage nur, es ist vielen Menschen hierzulande nicht mehr bewusst, dass das ein Krieg oder militärische Auseinandersetzung war, wo erstmals tatsächlich deutsche Streitkräfte selbst angegriffen haben. Aber im Prinzip ja. Es ging ja darum, die Radarstellung der Flugabwehr anzugreifen. Das Fachwort ist Suppression of Enemy Air Defense, also sozusagen die Flugabwehr auszuschalten. Und dafür gibt es bestimmte spezialisierte Flugzeuge mit speziellen Raketen, die darauf optimiert sind, die Radarstellung von Flugabwehrbatterien auszuschalten. Und dann ist diese Flugabwehr blind und kann...
Sowas hat die Bundeswehr auch und hatte die Bundeswehr damals auch schon.
Ja natürlich.
Und funktionierte auch in Europa.
Ja, mit dem Funktionieren, da gibt es sehr unterschiedliche Aussagen. Es gibt auch Leute, die behaupten, 250 Raketen und keiner hat getroffen. Das kann ich nicht beurteilen, das weiß ich nicht. Aber es gab auch eine Rakete, die in Ungarn landete. Dumm gelaufen, weil es eine Stellung relativ nah an der Grenze war. Da ist das eine oder andere sicherlich schief gelaufen. Aber es bleibt einfach zum ersten Mal deutsche Schüsse nicht in Selbstverteidigung.
Und was hat das mit der Bundeswehr angestellt, dieser Einsatz im Balkan jetzt mal das Ganze gesehen?
Was es angestellt hat, kann man eigentlich noch nicht so absehen. Der läuft ja noch. Müssen wir uns hier bewusst sein. Kosovo, gerade jetzt in diesen Tagen geht es wieder richtig rund. Gestern Abend ist die Entscheidung gefallen, dass gut 500 deutsche Soldaten der Eingreifreserve darunter verlegt werden. Also das ist noch lange nicht vorbei. Der Einmarsch von Bodentruppen der NATO im Kosovo ist jetzt ziemlich genau 12 Jahre her. Das war Juni 1999.
Es gibt uns Gelegenheit, noch mal kurz auf die eigentliche Struktur der Bundeswehr zu schauen. Ich glaube, man kann sich derzeit irgendwie ein bisschen schwer vorstellen, was macht eigentlich die Bundeswehr so personell, strukturell aus? Sie ist geschrumpft, sie soll weiter schrumpfen.
Sie ist gerade dabei, massiv umgebaut zu werden.
Woraus besteht die Bundeswehr? Was sind so die nennenswerten Strukturen? Es gibt einen Minister, das ist klar, darunter gibt es diverse Generäle. Oh nein, so einfach ist es natürlich nicht.
Es gibt einen Minister und darunter gibt es zwei Beamte und zwei parlamentarische Staatssekretäre und ganz viele Verwaltungsabteilungen. Und es gibt die Streitkräfte. Und da gibt es ganz viele Generäle. Da gibt es den Generalinspektor, der ist im Grunde genommen Teil des Ministeriums, aber jetzt auch Chef der ganzen Truppen unter ihm. Es gibt demnächst rund 175.000 Soldaten. Also bis vor einem halben, dreiviertel Jahr war die Zielgröße immer noch 250.000. Also da ist schon deutlich abgebaut worden. Zum Vergleich, in den Zeiten des Kalten Krieges, was wir erwähnt haben, mit den ganzen Wehrpflichtigen, war die Friedenstärke der Bundeswehr knapp eine halbe Million. Also das ist schon unglaublich reduziert worden.
Da muss es viel Langeweile gegeben haben.
Hat sicherlich auch, natürlich. Aber Stichwort Professionalisierung. Also ein deutlich kleinerer Laden, der deutlich professioneller werden soll. Gut, dann gibt es natürlich die bekannten Bereiche Heer, Luftwaffe, Marine. Es gibt auch, das ist wahrscheinlich weniger bekannt, die sogenannte Streitkräfte-Basis, die eigentlich alles zusammenfasst, was so zum Betrieb eines von Militär so nötig ist. Von Logistik bis hin zur Militärpolizei. Das ist noch mal separat von Her und Sofort. Und dann gibt es natürlich noch die Sanität. Oder was meintest du jetzt?
Ich habe mich da wenig mit beschäftigt. Ich frage einfach mal, ganz doof, weil wenn du jetzt sagst, naja, was war das, die Einsatzkräftereserve?
Jaja, die Eingreifreserve.
Eingreifreserve. Ich meine, auch solche Teile müssen ja irgendwo dazugehören. Ich konnte das halt jetzt gerade nicht so richtig einordnen.
Das ist dann noch was anderes.
Gerade bei so einem Auslandseinsatz, was jetzt wirklich zum Einsatz kommt. Also ist es das Her, was da ist, oder ist es vor allem die Luftwaffe?
Das hängt ja immer vom Einsatz ab. Also zur Piratenbekämpfung am Horn von Afrika schickt man weniger das Her, weil die nicht über Wasser laufen können, sondern da schickt man die Marine. Also manchmal ergibt es sich einfach aus der Art des Einsatzes.
Und das in einem christlichen Abendland. Können alle wieder nicht übers Wasser gehen.
Das Fass machen wir jetzt nicht auf.
Sanität, Streitkräfte-Basis, Herdluftwaffe, Marine. Die großen Truppenteile, sagst du?
Truppenteil ist wieder der... Teile dieser Organisationsstruktur. Die natürlich alle bestimmte Aufgaben auf bestimmte Dinge optimiert sind. Und jetzt zum Beispiel, was den Kosovo angeht, da wird im Wechsel immer ein deutsches Bataillon, das ist ein Flugabwehrraketenbataillon in diesem Fall, aber das spielt keine Rolle, da wird also ein Bataillon vorgehalten, wo die Leute wissen, dass sie im Ernstfall innerhalb von sieben Tagen verlegen müssen, wie das die Militärjagdung heißt, also darunter geschafft werden, als Verstärkung.
Und der Generalinspekteur ist, also was mich jetzt interessiert, ist vor allem in dem Moment, wo die Politik sagt, okay, alles klar, das tun wir, weil letztlich ist es ja die Politik, die die Vorgaben macht. Die Bundeswehr kann jetzt nicht selber entscheiden, auch da unten brennt es gerade zu schön, da wollen wir jetzt mal hingehen und löschen. Sondern die sind ja vollständig von der Politik und weiteren Sinne eigentlich vom Parlament und damit von allen irgendwie abhängig. Trotzdem muss es ja für eine effiziente Durchführung solcher Aktionen auch eine gewisse Eigenverantwortung geben. In dem Moment, wo man sagt, okay, wir greifen jetzt da ein. Gut, die NATO und ähnliche Verflechtung sind jetzt nochmal ein anderes Thema. Aber ab welcher Stelle wird die Bundeswehr eigenständig und wer entscheidet dann über wen?
Also es gibt den politischen Auftrag, der wird im Grunde genommen von der Regierung formuliert, vom Kabinett beschlossen und vom Bundestag gebilligt. Muss man auch noch dazu sagen, das Parlament kann ja einen solchen Vorschlag der Regierung zur Entsendung von Soldaten nur billigen oder ablehnen. Die können es nicht verändern. Also die können nicht sagen, hör mal Bundesregierung, du willst da 5000 Leute hinschicken, wir finden 3000 Reichen. Das geht nicht. Hopp oder Top, das muss vorher ausgehandelt werden. Das wird natürlich vorher ausgehandelt, weil die Bundesregierung natürlich vorher sondiert, wofür kriegen wir eine Zustimmung des Parlaments oder nicht. Dann gibt es dieses Mandat, was der Bundestag erteilt, und dann gibt es sozusagen den Auftrag an die Streitkräfte, jetzt macht mal. Und dann ist es im Wesentlichen in der Verantwortung der Streitkräfte, natürlich dann auch wieder in dieser internationalen Struktur. Ich sagte ja, sowas passiert ja immer nur im Zusammengehen, im Kontext. Das heißt de facto hängt es wieder davon ab, was hat die NATO für einen Operationsplan geschrieben? Klammer auf, immer unter deutscher Beteiligung. Klammer zu. Was steht da drin? Und letztendlich hat das Kommando bei diesen Operationen einen NATO-Befehlshaber. Also, die Deutschen, die in Afghanistan sind, stehen letztendlich unter dem Kommando des Kommandeurs der ISAF-Truppen in Afghanistan, das ist in der Regel ein Amerikaner, der Dienen seine Anweisungen gibt.
In der Regel ist es ein Amerikaner?
Ja, das hat sich in den letzten Jahren, weil die einfach die meisten Truppen stellen. Also, die stellen 100.000, die anderen 40.000. Dann ist schon klar, wer bestellt, bezahlt. Und dann sagen die das schon. Aber es ist unerheblich, ob es ein Amerikaner ist oder ein anderer.
Auf jeden Fall ist das nicht aus der Bundeswehr heraus, sondern das ist einfach immer eingebettet in die NATO-Strukturen.
Oder EU-Strukturen oder bei UN-Operationen in diese blauen Helm-Peacekeeping-Strukturen. Also, dass die Bundeswehr alleine an der Stelle entscheidet, dass und was passiert, das haben wir ja nicht.
Und war die Bundeswehr selber schon mal Leiter einer solchen NATO-Einsatz?
Ja, wie ich ja sage, im Moment der Kommandeur im Kosovo derzeit ist ein Deutscher. Es gab auch schon deutsche Kommandeure des ISAF-Einsatzes. Das war aber, das muss ich mal zurückdenken. Ja, da kommen wir wieder in die etwas kompliziertere NATO-Struktur. De facto ist ein NATO-Zwischenhauptquartier im niederländischen Brunnsum, das sogenannte Joint Forces Command, ist die vorgesetzte Behörde für den ISAF-Kommandeur. Und der Befehlshaber in diesem NATO-Kommando ist ein Deutscher General. Also wir haben von der Struktur her eigentlich, ich sage mal in Klammern, das ist manchmal ein bisschen theoretisch, die Struktur, dass ein Deutscher Vier-Sterne-General einem amerikanischen General in Kabul seine Befehle geben kann. Theoretisch deswegen, weil natürlich, wie ich sagte, wer bestellt, bezahlt. Natürlich kann er dem seine Befehle geben, aber die sagen dann, Junge, guck mal, wie viele Leute wir haben und wie viel ihr habt und bleiben wir doch mal bei der Realität.
Ja, die Frage ist natürlich auch, inwiefern kommt wirklich der Einsatz immer von oben, der Befehl und die Entscheidung von oben, oder inwiefern entscheiden diejenigen, die wirklich vor Ort sind und die konkret mit einem Problem, also wie groß ist sozusagen immer die Autonomie der Einzelnen?
Das ist total unterschiedlich. Das kann man so generell nicht sagen. Das hängt sehr stark vom Einsatz, von der Situation. Also die, die normalerweise geben diese Befehlshaber, diese großen Hauptquartiere, die geben einen generellen Operationsplan vor. Die geben vor, was sind die sogenannten Rules of Engagement, was dürft ihr, was dürft ihr nicht. Dann gibt es noch die nationalen Vorbehalte. Also wenn zum Beispiel ISAF sagt, ihr dürft einem Flüchtenden hinterher schießen, wenn ihr wisst, dass er ein Taliban ist, und die Deutschen sagen, nein, machen wir nicht, dann ist das ein deutscher Vorbehalt. Jetzt mal sehr plakativ ausgedrückt. Aber auf der untersten Ebene, es gibt ja im deutschen Militär das Prinzip der Auftragstaktik. Schon mal gehört? Auftragstaktik heißt im Grunde genommen nichts anderes als, ich sag dir, welche Ziele du erreichen sollst und auf welchem Weg du das machst, ist dein Ding. Also eigentlich, man könnte es auch fast als Einführung des gesunden Menschenverstandes. Auch da ist dir die Frage, ob das... Also das ist aber ein Ansatz, den es im deutschen Militär schon länger gibt. Dass Theorie und Praxis und Anspruch und Wirklichkeit, kann man immer noch reden, aber der Anspruch ist schon zu sagen, das Ziel ist definiert und den Weg bestimmt der, der sozusagen am nächsten dran ist und in diesem Umfeld ist.
Jetzt ist ja dieser ganze Bosnien- und Kosovo-Einsatz, also einerseits läuft er noch, andererseits sehr komplex durch seine NATO-Verzahnung. Das ist ein bisschen schwierig zu fragen für mich, aber ich suche immer so ein bisschen nach den Auswirkungen, die das auf die Bundeswehr letzten Endes auch wieder gehabt hat, weil das ist ja alles so eine Kette von Entwicklungen. Und na klar, kommt auch immer wieder die Politik rein und es wird vor allem auch immer versucht, solche Einsätze irgendwie politisch natürlich zu deuten, abzuschotten auch vielleicht von der Öffentlichkeit. Aber was ist da jetzt real passiert? Was hat die Bundeswehr dort konkret bewirkt?
Auf dem Balkan meinst du? Also ich würde das ungern an der Stelle auf die Bundeswehr verengen. Ich würde immer fragen, was hat dieser multinationale Militäreinsatz bewirkt? Und ich denke im Kosovo hat er schon ein Ende der Repression der albanischen Bevölkerung bewirkt. Die Frage kann man natürlich für jeden Einsatz stellen, was ist erreicht worden oder ist auch nur ansatzweise erreicht worden, was man eigentlich vorgehabt hat. Gerade bei Afghanistan muss man sich im Moment diese Frage sehr stellen. Mehr oder weniger steht es im Grunde genommen auf der Kippe. Hat man erreicht, also jetzt hat man sich ja quasi auf das Ziel verständigt, wir wollen so weit kommen, dass wir die Afghanen in die Lage versetzen, dass sie selber für Sicherheit in ihrem Land sorgen können. Ob das wirklich erreichbar ist oder ob es jetzt auch nur ansatzweise erreichbar ist, würde ich ein Fragezeichen dran machen.
Ich weiß, du warst an vielen Orten, aber wo warst du jetzt im Balkan selber vor Ort?
Ich war im Kosovo mehrfach, überwiegend in den Prisrennen und Prishtina. Auch in Bosnien an verschiedenen Orten, von Sarajevo über Foccia bis ich weiß es schon nicht mehr.
Und hattest du den Eindruck, dass wenn du da warst, mit dem, was du dort gesehen und erlebt hast, wieder zurückkommst, dass die Wahrnehmung Deutschlands auf das, was da geschieht, was mit der Realität zu tun hat? Also ist unsere Medienwahrnehmung oder die Wahrnehmung, die du selbst destillierst aus deinem Umfeld heraus, dessen, was dort passiert, hat das was miteinander zu tun? Oder ist das komplett man dahin und es ist auf einmal alles total anders?
Ne, musst du sehen, ich bin ja nun auch Teil der Medien. Gerade bei Afghanistan hat mich immer eine gewisse Diskrepanz geärgert. Diese Diskrepanz zwischen dem überwiegend in Deutschland vermittelten Bild, wir bohren Brunnen und wir eröffnen Mädchenschulen. Und nicht zu sagen, wir sind hier, um auch zu kämpfen. Das war eine Diskrepanz, die ich eigentlich in den vergangenen Jahren allein schon deswegen wahrgenommen habe, weil auch meine Situation, in der ich mich in dem Land bewegt habe, sich brutal verändert hat. Als ich das erste Mal 2002 in Kabul war mit der Bundeswehr, hat die Bundeswehr bei einem örtlichen Unternehmer kleine Busse gemietet und uns damit durch Kabul gefahren.
Das war sozusagen kurz nach dem Einmarsch der Amerikaner, nach dem Wesen des Landes, erstmal so freigerunden.
Genau, das war so im Frühjahr oder Sommer 2002, also ein gutes halbes Jahr danach. War gar kein Thema. Dann sind wir irgendwo in Kabul ausgestiegen, haben uns mal umgeguckt und freundlich mit dem Polizisten auf der Verkehrsinsel, soweit das möglich war, hinter seinem Maschinengewehr ein bisschen geplaudert und dann wieder im Bus und weitergefahren. Das würde heute kein Mensch mehr machen. Oder ein paar Jahre später bin ich mit einer Kollegin von einer NGO, weil einfach einen ganzen Nachmittag mit ihr im Jeep, nur wir beide alleine in so einem Jeep, auch durch Kabul gefahren, mal hier geguckt, mal da geguckt, würde heute auch keiner mehr machen. Weil sich die ganze Sicherheitslage für Ausländer deutlich zum Schlechteren verändert hat. Es gibt Ausländer, die das machen, die dort leben, gar keine Frage. Aber die generelle Situation ist eine andere geworden.
Okay, bleiben wir mal in Afghanistan. Ich glaube, man versucht, das in Balkan zu verorten.
Nein, wir reden auch gerne noch über den Balkan. Entschuldigung, das will ich nicht abhören.
Ich sage auch keinen Fehler, wenn du das für exemplarischer hältst.
Ja, also Balkan ist so ein bisschen der Punkt. Also wenn wir uns Bosnien angucken, Bosnien ist eigentlich nur noch dem Namen nach ein militärischer Einsatz. Damit 200 Manneken, 200 Deutsche sind da, glaube ich, noch. Oder sind 200 insgesamt, ich weiß es schon gar nicht mehr. Also das ist im Prinzip eine Polizeimission jetzt. Da muss die EU, wenn überhaupt, mit Beratern, mit Polizisten und so weiter, da wird Militär nicht gebraucht. Im Kosovo waren eigentlich alle, die das beobachten, bis vor einer Woche oder anderthalb Wochen der Meinung, ja, was soll das, warum stehen da noch 6000 Soldaten der NATO und fast 1000 Deutsche und ist doch alles wunderbar und können wir abbauen? Und dann ist das in den vergangenen Tagen quasi explodiert und brutal gekippt und hat gezeigt, wie labil die ganze Situation dann noch ist.
Das waren jetzt Angriffe von Serben, also aber eher Zivilisten?
Ja, Zivilisten mit Kalaschnikovs und Handgranaten. Ja, das ist ja das Problem. Ja, natürlich, die gibt es halt. Aber das ist natürlich eine sehr schwierige Gemengelage, die mit dem Verhalten der kosovarischen Regierung, mit dem Verhalten der serbischen Regierung, mit Zollgrenzen, Zollschränken und natürlich der Spaltung innerhalb des Kosovo selbst zu tun hat. Dass es natürlich eine serbische Minderheit gibt, die sieht, dass sie de facto von ihrem Mutterland abgekoppelt wird durch den Staat, in dem sie jetzt leben und durch die Mehrheitsgesellschaft. Und das führt zu gewaltsamen Auseinandersetzungen, die sich sehr, sehr übel entladen haben. Also Sachen, die auch hier gar nicht so mitgenommen oder bekannt werden. Also wo auch gezielt auf in diesem Fall polnische Soldaten geschossen wurde oder auf einen Hubschrauber von K4 geschossen wurde. Also das ist schon eine Nummer.
Im Prinzip wiederholt sich jetzt noch mal im Kleinen das, was man vorher hatte. Vorher waren es die albanische Minderheit, die vor der serbischen Mehrheit beschützt werden müsste. Und jetzt hat man das im Kleinen noch mal andersrum.
Ja, wobei natürlich der Unterschied ist, da marschiert jetzt nicht die kosovarische Spezialpolizei ein und macht Jagd auf Serben. Obwohl aus serbischer Sicht ist es genau so, weil die albanische Mehrheit oder die kosovarischen Regierungsinstitutionen die Zollgrenze über die Zollposten übernommen haben. Und dann kommen wir an den Punkt, dass die Serben sagen, aus unserer Sicht ist Kosovo nach wie vor ein Teil Serbiens. Und deswegen erkennen wir natürlich nicht irgendwelche Zollstempel aus dem Kosovo an. Und so hat sich das Ganze dann ziemlich schnell hochgeschaukelt. Und die gegensätzliche Abneigung, um es mal zurückhaltend auszudrücken, ist natürlich noch sehr, sehr massiv da.
Das heißt, ist es schon so, dass der NATO-Einsatz dort noch die labile Situation eigentlich im Griff hält?
Ja, im Moment ist es so. Und ich sagte ja vorhin, wenn jetzt 500 deutsche und fast 200 österreichische Soldaten als Eingreifreserve darunter geschickt werden, also wenn noch mal aufgestockt wird, heißt es, dass die NATO die Situation schon als recht brenzlig ansieht.
Und wie viel Kontakt hattest du denn so mit der Bevölkerung, mit lokalen Leuten, mit Betroffenen in der Kosovo-Region?
Sehr unterschiedlich. Also im Kosovo findet man ja eher jemand, der Englisch kann. Und dann hat man immer wieder mit Leuten Gespräche.
Und was war so dein Gefühl, wie diese Gesamtmenge-Lage dort wahrgenommen wird?
Also ich habe mich ja überwiegend im Stationierungsbereich der Bundeswehr, also da dann im Raum Prisren aufgehalten, wo die starke, massive albanische Mehrheit, die natürlich voller Begeisterung, zumindest direkt nach dem Einmarsch, die die Bundeswehr wahrgenommen haben. Ich war auch da, als der damalige Kanzler Schröder dahin fuhr. Und das war für ihn lebensgefährlich, nicht weil jemand auf ihn geschossen hätte, sondern weil ihn eine begeisterte Menge fast erdrückt hätte. Also es war irre. Ich stand da fast schon zu nah dran vor der Kathedrale. Und dann konnten nur Fallschirmjäger mit Mühe und Not verhindern, dass wirklich die begeisterte Masse diesen Kanzler erdrückt. Also es war irre. Ich glaube, so viel Jubel hat er noch nirgendwo gekriegt.
Nachvollziehbar, ich meine.
Die Wahrnehmung einfach als unser Befreier sozusagen.
Das ist natürlich eine Rolle, die so ein Politiker auch mal ganz gerne durchlebt.
Ja, das kommt ja diesen Tagen selten genug vor. Oder generell selten genug vor.
Na gut, ich meine, es ist jetzt natürlich schwierig, in so einer Situation jetzt so diffizile Meinungen zu hinterfragen, die vielleicht zu dem Zeitpunkt so noch gar nicht existierten. Das Ganze muss sich dann eher über die Zeit relativieren. Na gut, Afghanistan, da müssen wir jetzt dann doch noch mal draufkommen, weil das ist natürlich das große, dicke Ding. Und das ist natürlich auch etwas, wo du jetzt schon mehrfach angesprochen hast, wo so Anspruch und Realität offensichtlich doch sehr weit auseinanderklaffen.
Ja, sagen wir mal, vermittelte Anspruch und vermittelte Wahrnehmung in den letzten Jahren, was sich ein bisschen geändert hat.
Meinst du, wenn man es von vornherein anders vermittelt hätte, dann wäre es nicht so schlimm?
Das weiß ich nicht. Also es gibt gewisse Dinge, die in der deutschen Wahrnehmung so ein Huch, was ist denn das, ausgelöst haben, was vielleicht auch etwas anders aufgenommen worden wäre. Wenn man von vornherein ein bisschen ehrlicher mit diesem Einsatz umgegangen wäre.
Was ist denn aus deiner Sicht so die Ist-Situation in Afghanistan? Wie muss man sich das vorstellen?
Die Ist-Situation ist, dass alle westlichen Regierungen sich ein bisschen selbst gefesselt haben, weil sie alle verkündet haben, bis 2014 sind unsere Kampftruppen raus. Was ich für relativ unsinnig halte, in so einem Konflikt der Gegenseite zu sagen, ihr müsst noch so und so lange durchhalten und dann ist ja eh gut. Ein bisschen übertrieben, aber das ist schon so ein bisschen der Eindruck. Es findet so ein Wettstreit statt. Wer ist eigentlich in der Lage, den Afghanen zu sagen, wir verschaffen euch ein Land, in dem ihr jetzt mal, es geht noch nicht mal um Demokratie und all das, was da der westliche Mensch als Rucksack mitschleppt, sondern in dem ihr nur in einer relativen Sicherheit lebt, dass ihr nicht totgeschossen werdet.
Gibt es denn überhaupt so die Nation Afghanistan überhaupt so? Man hört so viel von Stämmen und Nord- und Südunterschieden und so.
Ja, es gibt massive Unterschiede. Da müsste man vielleicht eher ein Afghanistan kennen. Ich bin in dem Sinn kein Afghanistan-Kennner, gebe ich darauf hinzu. Aber es hat ja trotz aller Unterschiede zwischen Nord und Süd, trotz der verschiedenen Stämme, gibt es dieses Gebild der Afghanistan als Staat ja schon sehr, sehr lange. Und wenn wir uns an Erfahrungen der Briten im 19. Jahrhundert erinnern, dann spielte diese innere Zersplitterung gar keine Rolle, wenn es darum ging, einen äußeren Feind rauszuwerfen.
Und damit ist das Land ja schon seit langer, langer Zeit regelmäßig beschäftigt.
Ja, und relativ erfolgreich. Bestimmt. Briten, Russen, wer auch immer. Die Frage ist jetzt, sieht man das, was die NATO, was die ISAF da machen, ist das nur Ursupator Nummer 25 oder ist es ein anderer Ansatz? Und man kann natürlich die Meinung vertreten, es ist ein anderer Ansatz, weil das Ziel eigentlich ist zu sagen, da soll eine afghanische Regierung in die Lage versetzt werden, selber mit diesem Land fertig zu werden und selber für Sicherheit zu sorgen. Das ist ja das erklärte Ziel derzeit. Das erklärte Ziel der Gegenseite ist natürlich zu zeigen, ihr schafft das gar nicht. Also gerade in den letzten Tagen und Wochen haben ja gezielte Angriffe von Aufständen, sind so Taliban, das Haqqani-Network, wer auch immer, auf Schlüsselfiguren. Gouverneur von Kandahar oder Oberbürgermeister von Kandahar, Bruder, Halbbruder von Kasei und ähnliches hat ja gezielt zugenommen. Heute Morgen gab es wieder einen Anschlag in Kunduz, also quasi im deutschen Kernbereich.
Wo warst du?
In Afghanistan, Kabul, Mazar-i-Sharif, Kunduz, Falsabad und ich glaube noch ein paar andere. Aber ich war da immer mit der Bundeswehr unterwegs. Also muss ich als eins noch, hätte ich vielleicht zu Anfang sagen müssen.
Entbettet Journalist, ja?
Ja, de facto ja. Ich bin kein Kriegsreporter. Ich sehe mich auch nicht so. Ich sehe mich als politischer Journalist, der über Krisengebiete und Krisen schreibt und deswegen auch da hinfährt, um zu gucken, worüber er schreibt, aber ich bin nicht der klassische Kriegsreporter, der sich immer an der Frontline rumtreiben lässt. Ja, das wird manchmal so ein bisschen verwechselt, aber den Anspruch erhebe ich nicht und deswegen sage ich auch ganz offen in Afghanistan, ich fahre nicht auf eigene Faust durchs Land.
Ich glaube, das ist auch ein bisschen tödlich.
Es gibt Leute, die das machen, die das auch recht erfolgreich machen und die einfach das Land so kennen, dass sie es machen können.
Aber dazu muss man es auch gut kennen.
Also was so ein bisschen peinlich ist, aber das sagt vielleicht auch was über die deutsche Medienlandschaft und ist damit wieder ein anderes Thema. Deutschland ist zwar der drittgrößte Truppenstelle in Afghanistan, ich wüsste jetzt aber keinen einzigen deutschen Journalisten, der fest in Afghanistan stationiert ist. Der letzte war der Christoph Reuter vom Stern, der ist aber vor ein, zwei Monaten da rausgegangen, weil er jetzt auch einen anderen Job macht. Aber das war der einzige Deutsche, der auf Dauer im Land lebte und darüber berichtet hat.
Und wie ist das bei den Amerikanern?
Also wenn man sich anguckt, wie viele Leute Washington Post, New York Times, Wall Street Journal, CNN, AP und so weiter, da gibt es auch niederländische Zeitungen, die haben dann, das sind zwar dann freie Mitarbeiter, aber die auch Niederländer sind und für niederländische Medien berichten.
Und die zumindest, aus welchem Grund auch sonst vor Ort sind, um einfache Medien zu berichten und in Kontakt zu bleiben.
Natürlich. Und woran liegt das? Da müsste man dann eine Mediensendung drüber machen.
Das ist ja eh schon hier Politmedienmixing. Ich bin schon weit vom Thema abgekommen.
Ja gut, kann man wieder zurückkommen.
Passt aber zusammen.
Ja, natürlich. Also es ist so ein bisschen auch mit, was sind die deutschen Medien für sowas bereit zu investieren, auszugeben.
Interessiert es keinen? Ist es kein Markt?
Man hat fast den Eindruck. Ich weiß es nicht wirklich. Natürlich haben die großen, also die ARD, ZDF, deutsche Presseagentur, die haben Ortskräfte, also einheimische Journalisten als Stranger, also Afghanen, die auf Englisch Meldungen zuliefern. Das haben sie alle. Aber sie haben alle nicht den Deutschen, der in Kabul sitzt, sondern meinetwegen in Mazar-e Sharif oder so.
Ist das vielleicht der Grund, warum man immer das Gefühl hat, dass einfach, wenn dann mal was passiert, dass es sich im Wesentlichen als Aufzählung von so ein paar zusammengetragenen Fakten liest, so Bombe hochgegangen, drei Verletzte, vier Tote.
Ja, in der Tat.
Das ist aber eigentlich kein besonders guter Zustand, oder?
Ja, das ist in der Tat kein guter Zustand. Ich weiß auch nicht, wenn man mit Leuten darüber redet, die vielleicht zu was entscheiden könnten, dann ja, Kosten und Nutzen und Interesse und ja.
Hast du denn das Gefühl, dass das Thema Bundeswehr hier eigentlich keine interessiert?
Ich habe das Gefühl, es gibt so ein punktuelles Interesse. Wir sprachen mal nicht eingangs über das freundliche Interesse. Ja, schon so ein bisschen, aber es gibt ein Interesse, wenn was passiert. Also bei herausragenden Ereignissen, aber es gibt kein permanentes.
Hältst du das für berechtigt? Du findest das ja offensichtlich sehr interessant.
Ja, meine Leser auch übrigens.
Was ist denn interessant an der Bundeswehr?
Hast du übrigens schon gesagt, dass ich einen Blog schreibe, wie das heißt?
Ja, Augen geradeaus.
Punktnet, ja.
Punktnet, genau.
Entschuldigung.
Ist auch in den Links.
Ich bin der Meinung, dass Streitkräfte ein Teil unserer staatlichen Struktur sind. Und dass man sie genauso im Auge behalten muss, wie man auch andere staatliche Strukturen im Auge behält, jetzt aus journalistischer Sicht. Ich will jetzt nicht diesen Hochtram-Begriff erwähnen, aber Streitkräfte sind ein essenzieller Bestandteil eines Staates. Und den sollte man im Auge behalten. Ich sage jetzt nicht mal wohlwollend oder ablehnend oder kritisch, man sollte ihn im Auge behalten. Das finde ich eigentlich schon recht wichtig. Das finde ich auch jetzt aus meiner Sicht wichtig gegenüber den Soldaten, also den Leuten, die in diesen Streitkräften Dienst tun. Ich glaube, die haben ein ganzes, ganz massives Problem, nämlich die Wahrnehmung, dass sie von dieser Gesellschaft eigentlich links hingelassen werden.
Den Eindruck habe ich auch so ein bisschen. Vor allem weil es ja auch auf der einen Seite ist das so eine pathetische Unternehmung. Ich bringe mich für die Gesellschaft ein, ich verteidige den Staat, ich sichere Wohlstand, Realität und alle meine Freunde mit meinem eigenen Leben und so weiter. Man hat da einen Eid und ein großer Zapfenstreich und viel Trara. Und ich bin mir sicher, dass das viele auch beherzt leben. Vielleicht nicht alle, die wirklich bei der Bundeswehr sind, dass jetzt in einem warmen, wolligen Gefühl aufgehen, wie gut sie der Welt und ihrer Gesellschaft Diener zutragen. Aber dass das natürlich schon ein Teil davon ist. Und auf der anderen Seite eben diese Diskrepanz. Ich erlebe das auch genauso. Das ist auch ein bisschen so ein Grund, warum ich jetzt hier eigentlich mit dir auch ein bisschen darüber reden wollte. Dass es ein Riesenteil dieser Gesellschaft ist, der mittlerweile halt rausgeht. Also in 80er Jahren konnte einem der Bundeswehr immer so ein bisschen egal sein. Die saßen alle so in ihren Kasernen und würfelten. Da machte man so seine Scherzchen drüber. Und diesen Gedanken an den Ernstfall, den wollte man ja sowieso nicht ausleben, weil der sollte ja am besten gar nicht erst kommen. Das wäre eh vorbei. Man hat auch nicht das Gefühl, dass es dann noch viel helfen würde, eine Bundeswehr zu haben. Aber jetzt ist es irgendwie ganz anders. Jetzt haben wir so eine Situation. Ich war hier, die Freiheit Deutschlands wird auch am Hindukusch verteidigt. Ich weiß nicht, wie du zu diesem Satz stehst, aber der hat ja auch eine Menge ausgelöst. Im Sinne von, wir sind jetzt wirklich da draußen, wir sind auch irgendwie in der Pflicht. Und es ist ja nun auch so, dass wir eben diese Globalisierung an allen Fronten haben. Dass das nicht nur ein wirtschaftlicher Aspekt ist, sondern dass die internationale Verflechtung extrem ist. Es ist ja so extrem, dass wir hier sicher sagen können, ja, Krieg werden wir jetzt hier demnächst nicht haben.
Er ist schon irre, aus deutscher Sicht ist er absolut irre.
Das konnte man vor 30 Jahren sagen, so ein Satz wäre denkwürdig gewesen. Und jetzt sagt man das halt einfach mal so. Aber es ist nachvollziehbar, dass durch diese industrielle, wirtschaftliche Verflechtung, die wir mittlerweile haben, überhaupt auch so Weltkriege in zunehmendem Maße so ein bisschen außen vor sind. Man könnte sich jetzt nicht vorstellen, dass die Chinesen irgendwann mal so ihren Hauptmarkt in den USA wegbomben. Natürlich gibt es genug Regionale.
Dann wäre er auch weg, wenn sie wegbomben würden.
Ja eben, dann wäre er halt weg und das macht ja alles keinen Sinn. Trotz alledem ist die Welt jetzt an Konfliktorten nicht arm.
Im Gegenteil, eher reicher geworden. Die Zahl der Regionaler, Lokaler und Nicht-Kriege hat massiv zugenommen. Aber wir wollten darauf hinaus die Leute, die jetzt bereit sind, mich dahin zu stellen, inklusive Gefahr für mein eigenes Leben.
Genau, und den Rest interessiert es gar nicht. Und irgendwie geht das Kino und macht das was ich.
Das ist ein Problem. Und deswegen sind, also was in manchen Kreisen sehr verteufelt wurde, zum Beispiel so etwas wie die Gefechtsmedaille oder die Tapferkeitsmedaille für Soldaten im Einsatz, die ja erst vor relativ kurzer Zeit eingeführt wurde, das ist einfach so ein Stück oder ein Versuch, ihnen ein Stück dieser Anerkennung zu geben. Also zu sagen, Leute, gut, euer Gehalt können wir nicht erhöhen, wenn wir auf den Bundeshaushalt gucken, aber wir können diese Leistung würdigen, das ist ja auch eigentlich der Sinn von Orden, ganz generell, egal wie man dazu stehen mag, wir können diese Leistung würdigen, indem wir euch diese Medaille verleihen. Und das hat für Soldaten, glaube ich, einen sehr, sehr hohen Stellenwert.
Aber wirklich?
Also, da ist auch wieder dieser etwas schizophrenerdeutsche Umgang. Ich habe neulich mit einem Hauptmann der Gebirgsjähe gesprochen, der in Afghanistan in ziemlich viel brenzligen Situationen war. Und der erzählte mir dann, als ich ihn neulich wieder traf, übrigens, ich hab die Tapferkeitsmedaille bekommen. Ja, das ist ja ein Ding. Ja, weil für dieses Gefecht oder diese Situation, von der er mir auch vorher schon mal erzählt hatte, er halt in Afghanistan. Und dann hab ich ihn gefragt, aber auch mich selber gefragt, das weiß er und das wissen die paar Leute, die dabei waren, als er diese Medaille gekriegt hat, aber nach außen wird sowas überhaupt nicht kommuniziert. Also, schauen wir uns irgendeine amerikanische Kleinstadtzeitung an. Wenn da der Private John Doe für seine Leistung im Afghanistaneinsatz irgendeinen Orden kriegt, dann ist aber die Kleinstadtzeitung hallo dabei. Und sagt, Mensch toll, einer von uns hier ausgezeichnet und so. Und in Deutschland wird das, ja, also die einzige Verleihung dieser Tatsache als Medaille war die erste, und die war dann halbwegs öffentlich, weil es halt die erste war. Aber danach ist es auch wieder so eine interne Sache außerhalb des Bequezter Öffentlichkeit geworden.
Man hat so das Gefühl, es ist irgendwie immer noch so ein bisschen der Schatten der Wehrmacht, der irgendwie über allem liegt. Und wer generell sich militärisch organisiert, ist entweder ein verkrabter Nazi oder ein sonstiger Weltkriegstreiber.
Also es gibt ja auch bestimmte politische Strömungen, die das so sehen und auch so kommunizieren. Also ich habe ein Problem damit, wenn jemand permanent von den Besatzungstruppen in Afghanistan spricht. Also um dieses Land zu besetzen, braucht es A, ein bisschen mehr, allein schon an Truppen. Und es ist ja auch ein anderer Ansatz. Und am besten dann noch kombiniert mit dem Wurf, die sind ja nur wegen dem Öl da. So richtig viel Öl gibt es in Afghanistan nicht.
Ist nicht gerade neulich irgendwas gefunden worden?
Nein, es ist immer wieder die Rede von Bodenschätzen, Gold, Kupfer und so weiter. Wobei, wenn man sich das anguckt, die, die im Moment am weitesten vorn sind bei der Ausbeutung dieser Bodenschätze, sind die Chinesen, die übrigens mit gar keinen Truppen da sind, aber schon mal langfristige Verträge für die Ausbeutung bestimmter Minen geschlossen haben. Also das ist ein anderer Ansatz. Wenn es darum gehe, dieses Land auszuplündern, wie ja manche zu glauben scheinen, dann würde man das nicht auf diese Weise machen mit diesen militärischen Eingreifen.
Wie kommen denn die Chinesen dann an diese Aufträge ran?
Die haben halt in Kabul gut verhandelt, offensichtlich.
Gut, ich meine, es ist ein Nachbarland, muss man mal sagen.
Ja, ich träume ja immer noch von dem Foto, was ich wahrscheinlich nie sehen werde. Bist du dir bewusst, dass der Verantwortungsbereich deutscher Soldaten bis zur chinesischen Grenze reicht?
Ich habe mal auf die Karte geguckt, mir war nicht ganz klar, ob der so ist.
Ja, ist so. Aber gut, dass dieser kleine Zipfel, dieser Badak-Schanen-Korridor...
Ist das ein Tal?
Ja, es ist irre gebirgig und schwer zugänglich und da ist eigentlich auch niemand wirklich, oder? Da ist niemand wirklich und ich nehme mal an, die Grenze dürfte nicht so markiert sein, weil das ist irgendwo im Hochgebirge, wo eh kein Mensch langkommt. Aber einer hat schon diese Vorstellung, deutsche Soldaten stehen an der chinesischen Grenze.
Es hat einfach was Abstruses. Ja, das stimmt. Afghanistan grenzt ja irgendwie an alles, was derzeit brenzlig riecht. Das ist ja auch das Irre, also auch diese Turkvölker im Norden als ex-Sovietisches Gebiet. Das ist nicht ohne. Der Iran, Pakistan, das ist ja...
Ja, und damit hast du jetzt die geostrategische Bedeutung des Landes.
Genau, und an der Stelle könnte man sich natürlich auch gleich wieder fragen, hat es dann nicht doch noch irgendwie so eine Tiefenwirkung, das militärische...
Eine Tiefenwirkung oder eine beabsichtigte Tiefenwirkung ist sicherlich, dass man in diesem geostrategisch wichtigen Land nicht ein Regime sich installieren lassen möchte, was man als Feind empfindet oder was ein potenzieller Gegner ist. Das ist sicherlich so, spielt auch eine Rolle dabei.
Aber 2014, wenn dann die Truppen wirklich abziehen?
Also die Kampftruppen, das müssen wir auch nochmal differenzieren. Es wird ja immer gesagt, die Ausbildung bleibt weiter eine Aufgabe. Also die Ausbildung afghanischer Soldaten, afghanischer Polizisten und so weiter. Also die eigentlichen Kampftruppen sollen bis dahin abziehen. Werden wir gucken müssen, ob das so funktioniert. Das ist eine Absichtsempfehlung. In Deutschland geht es ja nun so weit, dass die Forderungen der Opposition in die Richtung gehen. Denn in diesem Jahr muss es schon eine signifikante Reduzierung geben. Nun kann man darüber streiten. Das ist ja wieder das mit diesem politischen Ansatz, dass die Politik sagt, so jetzt haben wir 5.300 Leute, die wir dahin schicken. Und jetzt aus innenpolitischen Gründen sagen wir jetzt mal, es sollen demnächst nur 5.000 sein. Das sind innenpolitische Gründe, die darüber entscheiden. Da wird nicht geguckt oder da wird nur sehr marginal gefragt. Sagt mal Jungs, die ihr da seid, was bräuchtet ihr denn? Es gibt Leute, die sagen, man soll die Frösche nicht fragen, wenn man den Sumpf trockenlegen will. Gut, das ist auch ein Ansatz. Man sollte aber vielleicht trotzdem ein bisschen realistisch dann Sachen zugrunde legen und sagen, die haben ja einen Grund, warum die mit dieser Zahl da sind. Die ist ja in den vergangenen Jahren permanent aufgestockt worden. Dass man vielleicht an der Stelle sagt, wir fragen mal die Fachleute. Aber das ist in Deutschland nicht anders als in anderen Nationen. Innenpolitische Gründe sind viel ausschlaggebender als das, was vor Ort passiert. Also, pardon, dass die Amerikaner ihre Truppen reduzieren, hat auch mit bevorstehenden Wahlen in den USA zu tun. Hat auch mit Haushaltssituationen in den USA zu tun. Es ist keine Entscheidung, wo sich der US-Präsident hingesetzt hat und gesagt hat, so, hier meine Jungs aus der Generalität, jetzt erklärt mir doch mal, warum braucht ihr so und so viele Leute und wie lange braucht ihr die und wann können wir denn wie viel daraus holen? So funktioniert das ja nicht.
Aber ich meine, aus denselben Gründen sind sie überhaupt alle auch als Start.
Ja, aber da sind wir wieder, was ich zwischendurch mal mit der Auftragstaktik sagte. Wenn die Politik einfach nur sagen würde, wir definieren ein Ziel, das möchten wir erreichen. Meinen wir auch noch im folgenden Zeitrahmen. Und denen sagt, wie ihr das Ziel erreicht, das ist euer Ding.
Aber ist das Ziel überhaupt zu erreichen in Afghanistan?
Das ist dann noch die nächste Frage. Da traue ich mir im Moment keine Einschätzung zu. Wie waren wir darauf gekommen, weil wir nach der Wahrnehmung oder der Anerkennung von Soldaten gefragt haben. Also das hat auch ein bisschen was damit zu tun mit dem Nachwuchs. Es wird natürlich sehr schwer fallen, Leute zu finden, die sich auf sowas einlassen, wenn die dann auch noch im positivsten Fall das Gefühl haben, zu Hause ist den Leuten doch sowas von scheißegal. Das macht es ja nicht einfacher.
Du bist ja jetzt mit deinem Blog sozusagen ein richtiger Internetjournalist geworden. Das heißt, du hast ja jetzt auch eine ganz andere Front, eine ganz andere Diskussionsfront, als das vielleicht vorher der Fall war. Gerade jetzt im Hinblick auf diese permanente Diskussion um die Bedeutung und Anerkennung der Bundeswehr als solcher. Was machst du da im Netz für Erfahrung?
Also nun habe ich eine Leserschaft, die sehr stark natürlich interessiert ist an dem Thema, die auch sehr positiv gegenüber der Bundeswehr angestellt ist. Mit kleinen Ausnahmen, aber eigentlich ist das überwiegend so.
Ist das dann vor allem auch aus der Bundeswehr heraus?
Es ist sehr viel aus der Bundeswehr heraus. Also ich kann das ja immer nur grob abschätzen, die Kommentare sind ja auch alle unter Pseudonym. Ich kann das nur grob abschätzen aus den Rückmeldungen, die ich bekomme. Aber das sind dann Leute, die sagen, ich finde es gut, dass sie hier über dieses und jenes schreiben, was die normalen Medien schon gar nicht mehr interessiert. Und das finden wir bei ihnen. Oder bei dir oder wie auch immer. Also schon so ein Stück weit zu sagen, ok, du verschaffst uns auch ein Stück Wahrnehmung.
Ja und unabhängig von den und die anderen Blogs sozusagen.
Was machst du jetzt mit dir?
Vieles, was ein Blog rausbringt, wird ja dann auch in der Blogosphäre herumgetragen. Hast du den Eindruck, dass das bei dir auch so ist?
Relativ wenig. Also der Punkt ist, dass es in Deutschland, im Unterschied zum Beispiel zu den USA oder auch Großbritannien, kaum, fast keine Blogs gibt, die sich mit diesem Thema befassen. Also wenn es eine Hand voll ist in Deutschland, ist es viel. Es ist, also auch dieses Orchideenthema, dieser Minderheitensport, erstreckt sich auch auf die Blogosphäre. Also es gibt da, das macht es oder hat es für mich, als ich mit dem Blog über dieses Thema anfing, auch ein bisschen schwierig gemacht, es gibt diese Vernetzung und dieses Verlinken und Pipaput. Das gibt es da kaum, weil es halt zu wenig, die kritische Masse ist da nicht da. Also wenn man was über IT schreibt oder über Medien, dann zack, zack, zack, dann breitet sich das immer irre schnell aus. Bei dem Thema sehr, sehr zäh.
Kommen wir noch mal vielleicht auch auf Bundeswehr und Internet zu sprechen, jenseits...
Zwei Welten branden aufeinander.
Naja, aber ich meine, diese ganze Sicherheitsaspekt und Cyberwar-Diskussion ist ja nun auch gerade ein heißes Ding, wird ja sicherlich auch bei der Bundeswehr eine Rolle spielen.
Ja, natürlich.
Welche Rolle spielt es da?
Jetzt müssen wir noch ein paar Sachen auseinanderhalten. Cyberwar in diesem ganz strengen Sinne ist ja das, wo es darum geht, eigene Netze zu schützen, gegnerische Netze platt zu machen. Und da reden wir nicht über verunste Webseiten oder sowas, sondern da reden wir über Angriffe auf Waffen, Steuerungssysteme, also Kriegsschiffe, Panzer, Flugabwehrstellungen. All diese Dinge, das sind ja sozusagen Computer mit ein bisschen Peripherie.
Ja, aber ich meine, solche Angriffe wie dieser Stuxnetz-Virus, da auch die iranische Atomfabrik, haben ja gezeigt, dass das Ganze schon sehr weitgehend sein kann.
Ja, natürlich kann das sehr weitgehend sein. Deswegen geht es da auch, die Militärs sprechen immer von gehärteten Systemen, also auch gehärtete IT, das abzuschotten, was an der Stelle eine etwas andere Aufgabe ist, weil das ist ja nicht per se Software-off-the-shelf, noch nicht mal so wie die Software auf die Stuxnetz abzielte, die ja im Grunde genommen auch off-the-shelf war, sondern das sind sehr oft tailor-made Software-Lösungen, die eine Fregatte steuern, zum Beispiel, mit ihren Luftabwehrradaren und Raketen. Und da gibt es natürlich die andere Geschichte, und da ist die Bundeswehr vielleicht auch ein, ich weiß nicht, wie verwundbar sie wirklich ist, aber wenn man sich anguckt, ich sage immer, dass eine Krise begonnen hat, erkennt man darin, dass ganz viele Computer mit Windows-Logo in einen Raum getragen werden. Weil nämlich so ein moderner Gefecht stand, bei der NATO, bei der EU, bei der UN, bei der Bundeswehr, bei den Amerikanern, bei wem auch immer besteht aus endlosen Reihen voller Windows-Computer. Auf denen sie dann ihre Kommunikation, Lagebilder und so weiter haben. Da sitzen dann selbst entwickelte Software-Lösungen drauf. Manchmal hat man schon den Eindruck, dass die sich da in eine gewisse Monokultur begeben haben.
Das kann man wohl sagen.
Ja, das wird sich vielleicht auch noch ändern, wenn diese Verwundbarkeit einfach anders wahrgenommen wird oder besser wahrgenommen wird. Da bleibt sicherlich noch einiges zu tun. Das wäre die Analogie zu dem Atomkraftwerk, was Hacker in die Luft jagen, auf dem Weg über Schadsoftware. Die Analogie wäre ja dazu, dass Waffensysteme manipuliert werden. Also richtig klassische Dinge, die Bumm machen und Menschen tot machen.
Die Rakete aus dem Silo und so weiter.
Ja, genau so was. Und da denke ich, da sind sicherlich die Systeme besser geschützt. Und da reden wir nicht über Windows-Computer, die am Internet hängen. Das bin ich beruhigt. Ja, hoffentlich. Na gut, ich bin an einer anderen Stelle nicht beruhigt, weil ich dachte erst, du meinst einen anderen Ansatz. Dieses Stichwort Information Warfare ist ja auch Teil dieser ganzen Überlegungen mit Cyberwar. Was so die Internetpräsenz und Darstellung der Bundeswehr angeht, da ist sie sicherlich a, verwundbar und b, wäre das vielleicht auch noch deutlich verbesserungswürdig, bedürftig. Aber gut, das muss man gucken. Es ist immer die Rede davon, dass die mal auf ein anderes CMS umstellen. Wenn sie das hinkriegen würden, hätten die schon eine Menge geschaffen. Das ist wieder eine Frage von Geld.
Das gilt wahrscheinlich für die meisten Institutionen.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Es ist ein extrem weites Feld, deswegen kann ich mich das nicht zu sehr vertiefen. Aber natürlich Information Warfare ist ja auch die Frage von psychologischer Kriegsverführung.
Welch böses Wort! In Deutschland hieß das lange übrigens psychologische Verteidigung. Inzwischen heißt es Information Operations, wo die Amis ganz cool Psiops sagen.
Das war schon voll im Neusprech angekommen. Es ist wirklich ein echt schwieriges Thema für mich, weil es so viele Freunde hat. Langsam müssen wir es auch mal zu Ende bringen. Aber vielleicht noch ein kurzer Blick in die USA. Dieses Ding mit WikiLeaks und dem Verrat von Geheimnissen. Ihren Staatsproblem als jetzt ein Militärproblem. Aber im Falle von Bradley Manning war es ja jemand, der das aus dem Militärapparat herausgebracht hat, der halt die entsprechende Klassifizierung hatte und Zugang hatte auf Sicherheitsdokumente.
Ich weiß nicht, es gab mal eine Zahl, wie viele Leute hatten da Zugriff, das war irre.
Viele, ja.
Das war also so irre. Also wer so einen breiten Zugriff auf bestimmte Dokumente zulässt, der will sie nicht geheim halten. Das ist jetzt einfach mein Schloss da draußen. Also es gibt einen niederländischen General, den Tom van Loon, der immer sehr erfrischend ist in seinen Aussagen, der auf einer Tagung mal sagt, also wenn wir doch ehrlich sind, 80 Prozent von allen Informationen brauchen wir nicht geheim zu halten. 20 Prozent brauchen wir, nee, 70 Prozent brauchen wir gar nicht geheim zu halten. Das ist Unsinn, weil irgendwo findet es man sowieso. 20 Prozent müssen wir temporär geheim halten, weil wenn ein bestimmter Einsatz bevorsteht, muss das nicht unbedingt publik werden und gerade mal höchstens 10 Prozent sind auf Dauer geheimhaltungswürdig. Das finde ich einen sehr pragmatischen Ansatz und ich glaube, so ist es auch wirklich.
Aber die eigentliche Frage ist ja, diese Reaktion der USA auf diesen Verrat, ich weiß nicht, ob die extrem ist, auf jeden Fall ist sie stark. Also dieser Verrat wird da wahrscheinlich auch nochmal besonders mental belegt, so dieser Verrat an der Nation. Gibt es irgendwie, wenn man das so auf die Bundeswehr überträgt, könnte man sich sowas ähnliches da auch vorstellen. Hat es da genauso gesehen, gibt es da überhaupt dieses Problem zur Geheimhaltung?
Ja natürlich, bei Militär gibt es immer das Problem der Geheimhaltung. Es gibt ja auch Dinge, die werden aus gutem Grund geheim gehalten, weil es Menschenleben kostet, wenn es nicht geheim gehalten wird. Müssen wir uns einfach darüber klar sein. Das ist auch für mich als Journalist so ein Punkt, da ich sage, es gibt Dinge, manchmal erfährt man ja das eine oder andere, und es gibt Dinge, da sage ich auch, die verwende ich nicht, die publiziere ich nicht, weil ich weiß einfach, oder vielleicht erst viel später, weil ich weiß, dass das Menschenleben gefährden könnte, wenn ich jetzt damit etwas anfange. Und deswegen habe ich auch Probleme manchmal mit der Haltung, wir machen alles geheime öffentlich, weil Transparenz ist doch unser Ziel. Sorry, wenn Leute dadurch sterben, dann ist für mich da eine Grenze, und dann, das geht nicht.
Punkt.
Da bin ich auch nicht diskussionsbereit. Der andere Punkt ist, Bradley Manning hat ja keine Militärgeheimnisse verraten, muss man sich ja auch mal bewusst machen.
So einen Diplomaten? Die Frage ist, ob dieses Video, dieses Angriffsvideo auf dem Irak.
Genau.
Das wird sicherlich als Militärgeheimnis gesehen.
Ja, natürlich. Aber das wäre zum Beispiel so etwas, wo ich sagen würde, wo ist da das Geheimhaltungsbedürfnis? Jetzt mal ganz, ganz echt, wenn wir uns dieses Video angucken, mit all diesen schrecklichen Dingen, die da passiert sind, wo wäre da ein begründetes Interesse von Militärsgleich welcher Nation dieses Video geheim zu halten? Jetzt kann man sagen, da sind technische Daten eingeblendet, weiß ich nicht, die Auskunft geben könnten über Leistungsfähigkeit vom Waffensystem. Die kann man ja wegmachen. Man sieht ja Gunnvideos, die werden ja auch veröffentlicht. Also wir sollen ja nicht so tun, als wäre es das erste Gunnvideo, was wir gesehen hätten. Sondern im Gegenteil, jetzt auch gerade aus dem Irakkrieg, also teilweise werben ja Militärs damit. Guck mal, wie professionell und wie die Tövler, die das weggehauen haben, also was zum Henker ist an diesem Video geheimhaltungsbedürftig? Verstehe ich nicht. So, die andere Geschichte ist, er hat keine Militärgeheimnis verstanden. Also es ist sehr stark mental aufgeladen, wie du schon gesagt hast, es ist ein Verräter an unserer Nation. Ich weiß nicht, ob es das in Deutschland auch so gäbe, ich glaube, man würde von vornherein, wenn man wirklich ein Interesse an der Abschottung und Geheimhaltung bestimmter Daten hat, man würde sie nicht so breit zugänglich machen.
Das war auf jeden Fall der Fehler, den Sie gemacht haben.
Und wenn ich das richtig sehe, ich habe ja nur einen Teil dieser Sachen mir angeguckt, aber war da was dabei, was richtig secret gestempelt war? Also es gibt ja diese Geheimhaltungsabstufung, gibt es ja auch in Deutschland, wenn eine Verschlusssache nur für den Dienst gebracht wird, feistvertraulich, geheim und so weiter und immer höher. Das Problem ist ja immer, es gibt Dinge, die amtlich unter Verschluss gehalten werden, die wenn sie bekannt werden, nicht wirklich Schaden anrichten, die aber peinlich sind für Leute. Gibt es auch in der deutschen Verwaltung, nicht nur beim Militär, die gibt es überall in der deutschen Bürokratie und mein Eindruck ist manchmal, dass die große Angst der Bürokraten, ob mit oder ohne Uniform ist, dass da irgendwas an die Öffentlichkeit kommt, was sie schlecht darstellen lässt, wo sie dumm aussehen.
Was ja in dem Fall auch so ist.
Ja, natürlich, aber ist das etwas, was von Ausnahmen abgesehen, was die nationale Identität der USA gefährdet?
Eher nicht.
Eher nicht. Also ich sage deswegen bewusst von Ausnahmen abgesehen, es gab da, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, aus dem BAP für irgendwelche Cables, wo über Gespräche mit Oppositionspolitiker und so weiter berichtet wurde und diese Oppositionspolitiker, was natürlich sofort von den örtlichen Medien aufgegriffen oder von der örtlichen politischen Führung aufgegriffen wurde, um diese Opposition zu diskreditieren. Also das sind Sachen, da kann es heikel werden und da will ich auch nicht ausschließen, dass dadurch Menschen gefährdet werden. Man sagt, hier, du hast sich heimlich mit dem Armebotschafter getroffen und was ist unser Feind und du hast mit dem Feind kooperiert. Aber das ist dann noch eine Ausnahme davon.
Ja, Thomas, wir machen jetzt mal hier ein Ende. Man könnte wahrscheinlich noch ewig weiterreden, weil es eine etwas wilde Mischung aus Politik und Struktur und anderen Dingen war. Aber das ist nun mal genau die Gemengelage, in dem sich das Ganze abspielt. Wer Lust hat auf tägliche Updates, augen geradeaus.net.
Es gibt auch einen Twitter-Account, der genau so heißt. Den habe ich unter meinem Privatnamen, das ist thomas-wiegold. Was gibt es noch? Es gibt auch eine Facebook-Seite, die augen geradeaus heißt. Da werden aber im Wesentlichen nur die Blog-Inhalte gespiegelt, damit man auch auf Facebook mitkriegt, dass sie da sind.
Für Leute, die nur dort sind.
Ja, es gibt einige. Bei Google Plus habe ich es noch nicht automatisiert, das machen wir aber noch. Ja, das wäre es, glaube ich.
Alles klar. Ich sage mal vielen Dank.
Ja, aber gerne.
Und das war es, Chaosradio Express 184, wir bekämpfen die Sommerpause mit unregelmäßigen Neuigkeiten. Ich sage tschüss und bis bald.